Avant que la vidéo ne commence, j’ai une
question à vous poser : Vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu tous les livres dont ils
parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
1ère référence : The Principles of Psychology
(1890), William James
D’après le site de la bibliothèque nationale
américaine, les États-Unis accueillent 12
millions d’immigrants entre 1870 et 1900,
soit 1/6ème de la population en 1900. Cette
immigration massive n’est pas anodine pour
la société américaine, en particulier pour
le système éducatif. Elle le met au défi
d’intégrer un afflux massif d’élèves
qui ne parlent pas la langue et qui sont affectés
psychologiquement par leur changement de vie
et par leur nécessaire adaptation à une
nouvelle culture. Les psychologues américains
de l’époque sont donc mobilisés pour résoudre
ces problèmes pratiques.
Et le plus fameux d’entre eux est William
James. À 46 ans, il publie un des premiers
manuels de psychologie moderne, The Principes
of Psychology. Ce manuel synthétise le savoir
de la discipline de l’époque, ce qui renforce
sa crédibilité scientifique. Il a aujourd’hui
la valeur d’un texte fondateur qui est toujours
cité dans les cursus et dans les travaux
universitaires. D’ailleurs, James est le
premier à enseigner la psychologie aux États-Unis,
à Harvard, où il fonde également le laboratoire
de psychologie.
Pourtant, nous connaissons William James comme
philosophe : il est le plus célèbre philosophe
américain, et le penseur de référence du
pragmatisme. Mais en réalité, il a fini
par la philosophie. Il a d’abord étudié
la médecine à Harvard ; il s’est formé
à la psychologie en Allemagne, où les universités
étaient à l'avant-garde de la recherche
en psychologie ; ensuite, il est devenu prof
de médecine à Harvard ; puis de psychologie
; et enfin, il y a enseigné la philosophie.
Le fait que James soit médecin, psychologue
et philosophe lui donne une vaste perspective
intellectuelle, et cela rend son propos très
intéressant.
Ce livre, The Principes of Psychology, fait
1400 pages, et il a été écrit en 12 ans.
Il est si imposant — et du coup cher pour
l’époque — que James publie une version
abrégée 2 ans plus tard. Étant donné le
sujet et l’ambition du livre, ça pourrait
être bien plus difficile à lire. Le propos
est globalement clair. Des questions apportent
du dynamisme. Le style est plus littéraire
que technique ou scientifique, ce qui a d’ailleurs
été reproché à James (à l’époque,
la psychologie se revendique comme une science
sérieuse, et cela passe notamment par la
technicité du langage). Côtés points négatifs,
les paragraphes sont parfois bien longs et
certains développements théoriques ne sont
pas faciles à suivre.
Que retenir du fond du livre, maintenant ?
La première idée essentielle est celle du
« courant de conscience » (« stream of
consciousness » en anglais). Cette célèbre
métaphore psychologique signifie que nos
sensations, nos sentiments et nos pensées
se succèdent de manière continue et fluide
(comme un courant qui s'écoule) — il est
impossible de les découper. Imaginez une
rivière : même si l'eau change constamment,
la rivière reste la même. Avec cette conception,
James s’oppose à la thèse, largement acceptée
à l’époque, que la conscience est un produit
secondaire. L’idée du « courant de conscience
» repose sur la biologie darwinienne, parce
qu’elle conçoit la conscience comme une
activité de l'organisme qui a pour fonction
de l'adapter à l'environnement (sinon elle
n'aurait pas survécu dans l'espèce humaine).
Voir la conscience comme un courant a une
implication pratique importante : il faut
recourir à l’introspection pour étudier
la conscience, et non pas aux méthodes expérimentales
qui se développent à l’époque. Après,
James est bien conscient des limites de l’introspection.
La deuxième idée essentielle du livre concerne
l’émotion. James affirme que les émotions
primitives (comme la peur ou la colère) sont
ressenties après des modifications corporelles.
Autrement dit, l’émotion est une conséquence,
pas une cause. Le sens commun dit que je tremble
devant le danger parce que j’éprouve de
la peur — mais pour James, c’est l’inverse
qui est vrai : c’est parce que je tremble
devant le danger que j’éprouve de la peur.
Le médecin danois Carl Lange formule une
idée analogue à la même époque, donc la
théorie s’appelle aujourd’hui la « théorie
James-Lange de l’émotion ».
La troisième idée essentielle du livre concerne
l’habitude. James présente les habitudes
comme des mécanismes essentiels dans la vie
humaine (Aristote avait déjà dit que nous
sommes ce que nous faisons chaque jour). James
compare les habitudes à des chemins creusés
dans le cerveau qui permettent ensuite d'agir
automatiquement, sans penser. Lorsqu’un
homme répète une action, il renforce le
chemin neuronal associé, ce qui rendra l'action
de plus en plus facile et automatique. Une
habitude peut être bonne ou mauvaise — mais
elle est toujours puissante, et donc difficile
à changer. Comment réussir à changer ses
habitudes ? Grâce à la volonté.
C’est la quatrième et dernière idée essentielle
du livre. Pour James, la volonté est la capacité
à choisir délibérément un cours d'action
et à y adhérer, même face à la difficulté.
Elle est le pouvoir de diriger son attention,
de contrôler ses impulsions, et de persévérer
malgré les obstacles. Mais comment avoir
plus de volonté ? James compare la volonté
à un muscle : plus on s’en sert, plus elle
est forte.
Ce livre est incontournable en psychologie
pour plusieurs raisons. Il a d’abord contribué
à populariser la psychologie comme discipline
scientifique aux États-Unis, puis en Europe.
Il a plus particulièrement diffusé la discipline
dans les universités : l’existence d’un
gros manuel qui synthétise tout le savoir
disponible permet de créer plus facilement
des cursus de psychologie. Ensuite, certains
concepts de ce livre ont ouvert la voie à
des champs de recherche en psychologie (par
exemple sur l’interaction entre l’esprit
et l’environnement, sur les émotions, l’identité
et la personnalité). Enfin, le style d’explication
de James a été très influent. Son expression
moins formelle, plus conversationnelle a déteint
sur la manière dont les chercheurs en psychologie
communiquaient leurs résultats. Son talent
de vulgarisateur, grâce auquel il explique
des concepts théoriques complexes par des
métaphores et des anecdotes — ce talent
a contribué à faire de la psychologie une
discipline populaire. Après, James était
conscient des limites de la psychologie de
son époque. Il disait qu’elle n'était
pas encore une science, mais un espoir de
science.
2ème référence : Psychologie des foules
(1895), Gustave Le Bon
Voici ce que dit Mussolini à un journal en
1932 à propos du décès de Gustave Le Bon
: « Vous avez en France, dans le domaine
de la philosophie et de la science, des hommes
dont s’honore le plus l’humanité : Gustave
Le Bon par exemple. Je ne sais combien de
fois j’ai relu sa Psychologie des foules.
C’est un ouvrage capital auquel je me reporte
souvent. »
Ce livre est un, sinon l’ouvrage fondateur
de la psychologie sociale, la branche qui
étudie comment les hommes s’influencent
les uns les autres. Il a été un des premiers
à explorer en détail le fait que les individus
se comportent différemment lorsqu'ils sont
en groupe par rapport à leur comportement
lorsqu'ils sont seuls.
Après, ce livre a été critiqué pour son
manque de rigueur scientifique. Il faut dire
que Le Bon n’était pas psychologue de formation.
Il n’a même pas fini ses études de médecine
(c’est un « drop out », comme on dit aujourd’hui
à propos de certains entrepreneurs célèbres).
Au tout début de la vingtaine, il quitte
la faculté de médecine pour devenir une
sorte d’aventurier. Il parcourt l’Europe,
l’Asie, l’Afrique du Nord — et la matière
de ses récits de voyage fait de lui un archéologue
et un anthropologue. À partir de la quarantaine,
il passe de l’anthropologie à la psychologie.
Mais il n’est pas un véritable psychologue.
C’est un érudit qui écrit beaucoup sur
plein de sujets parce qu’il veut être reconnu.
Pour autant, ce que ce livre dit sur la dynamique
des foules et sur l'influence du groupe sur
l'individu — ces idées deviendront importantes
en psychologie sociale.
Sur la forme, Psychologie des foules fait
un peu moins de 200 pages. Il est divisé
en 3 livres : 1er livre, « l’âme des foules
» ; 2ème livre, « les opinions et les croyances
de foules » (c’est-à-dire le contenu de
l’âme des foules) ; et enfin 3ème livre,
le moins plaisant à lire, « classification
et description des diverses catégories de
foules ». Le style de Le Bon est globalement
clair, fluide, et même plutôt direct. On
n’est pas au niveau d’un vulgarisateur
du XXIe siècle, qui tutoie le lecteur et
lui raconte des anecdotes tirées de sa vie
personnelle — mais le propos de ce livre
est très accessible pour son époque. La
structuration en paragraphes est logique et
cohérente. Les arguments sont bien articulés.
Les phrases ne donnent pas l’impression
au lecteur qu’on lui maintient la tête
sous l’eau. Les questions apportent du dynamisme.
Le style de Le Bon est donc efficace. Mais
on peut quand même lui reprocher une certaine
emphase : il a tendance à décrire le comportement
des foules sur un ton alarmiste qui, à force,
ne fait pas naturel.
Maintenant, quel est l’essentiel à retenir
de ce livre ?
Pour faire simple, Le Bon, qui a l’ambition
de toucher un large public, surfe sur une
thèse en vogue à l’époque : la foule
étouffe la rationalité individuelle. Et
cela la rend dangereuse.
Comment Le Bon explique-t-il cette thèse
?
Il y a une unité mentale dans une foule.
Pour Le Bon, une foule n’est pas un simple
agrégat d’individus. Dans une perspective
psychologique, elle constitue au contraire
une entité une et indivisible, distincte
de la simple addition des éléments isolés
qui la composent. L’unité mentale est telle
que la foule est assimilable à une « âme
collective » transitoire, constituée par
la fusion des âmes individuelles dans une
même direction. Cette fusion des âmes fait
ressentir de l’ivresse à l’individu.
Comme Le Bon connaît les travaux sur l’hypnose
des psychologues (français, notamment) de
l’époque, il compare le phénomène psychologique
de la foule à une hypnose collective. Le
souci, c’est que cette hypnose collective
réduit à néant la moindre impulsion de
volonté individuelle. L’esprit critique
disparaît dans une foule. Du coup, un philosophe
y a la même valeur qu’un illettré, explique
par exemple Le Bon.
La comparaison avec l’hypnose sert aussi
à exprimer l’idée que la foule est influençable.
L’âme de la foule s’impose à tous les
individus par un phénomène de contagion
: l’idée dominante se répand dans les
esprits galvanisés par l’émotion commune,
jusqu’à substituer l’intérêt collectif
à l’intérêt individuel. Comme la foule
est d’ordinaire impulsive et irritable,
on peut l’exciter facilement et lui faire
parcourir rapidement la gamme des émotions
les plus contradictoires. Mais il ne faut
pas lui présenter une théorie élaborée,
des vérités nuancées et relatives. Seule
une idée simple, vague, absolue et présentée
sous la forme d’une image impressionnante
peut réussir à conquérir l’âme de la
foule. En effet, elle est dotée d’une imagination
puissante. C’est d’ailleurs cette imagination
puissante de la foule qui confère une dimension
mystérieuse et légendaire aux événements
collectifs.
Le caractère influençable de la foule crée
le même problème qu’avec un individu influençable
: la foule ne réussit pas à s’autodiscipliner.
Elle a donc besoin d’un meneur. Le Bon en
fait le portrait suivant : il s’agit d’un
un orateur persuasif qui croit fermement en
l'idéal commun ; il est prêt à tout sacrifier
pour cet idéal ; les gens voient ses paroles
comme sacrées, suivent ses ordres sans question
et le considèrent comme une légende ; les
gens croient que le meneur peut les guider
vers leurs rêves. Le Bon donne l’exemple
de Napoléon. Son grand prestige le rendait
capable de dominer émotionnellement les masses
en paralysant le jugement des individus. « Malmenez
les hommes tant qu’il vous plaira, écrit
Le Bon, massacrez-les par millions, amenez
invasions sur invasions, tout vous est permis
si vous possédez un degré suffisant de prestige
et le talent nécessaire pour le maintenir.
»
Traduit en dix-sept langues, Psychologie des
foules est un véritable best-seller, qui
connaît quinze éditions en moins d’un
quart de siècle partout dans le monde. Il
sera influent en psychologie — malgré la
faible crédibilité scientifique de Gustave
Le Bon — parce qu’il impose la nécessité,
pour cette science naissante, de ne pas se
limiter à l’étude de l’esprit de l’homme
individuel, mais d’étudier également l’esprit
du groupe humain, esprit collectif qui ne
se réduit pas à l’addition des esprits
individuels.
Toutefois, l’influence de ce livre dépasse
largement la psychologie. Comme le révèle
le fait que Mussolini en soit fan, il fascine
les hautes sphères politiques de l’époque.
Les dirigeants sont très sensibles au message
de Le Bon selon lequel la foule est soit un
danger, soit un puissant instrument pour le
meneur qui sait orienter la foule. Ce succès
intellectuel est en bonne partie une question
de contexte : les journées révolutionnaires
européennes qui ont éclaté tout au long
du XIXe siècle ont terrorisé les élites
politiques.
Mais la pensée occidentale rompra avec la
diabolisation des foules après la Première
Guerre mondiale. Le terme de « masses » (qui
correspond davantage à une terminologie économique)
remplacera le terme « foules », et la comparaison
avec l’hypnose sera abandonnée. Les sociologues
et les politistes proposeront même l’idée
qu’un rassemblement d’individus n’est
pas forcément irrationnel.
3ème référence : Trois essais sur la théorie
sexuelle (1905), Sigmund Freud
Au tournant du XXe siècle, les adversaires
de Freud disqualifient sa théorie comme un
« pansexualisme », c’est-à-dire qu’elle
explique tout acte (pan veut dire « tout
» en grec ancien) — elle explique tout
acte par une motivation sexuelle qui n’est
pas consciente. Freud se défend en disant
que l'importance du désir sexuel dans la
vie humaine est une vieille idée (l’idée
de l’Éros chez Platon, par exemple, ou
plus récemment la métaphysique de l’amour
de Schopenhauer). Après la publication des
Trois essais sur la théorie sexuelle, les
critiques s’en donnent à cœur joie : Freud
est un « libertin viennois » (Freud a vécu
la majeure partie de sa vie à Vienne) — Ies
critiques disent que Freud est un « libertin
viennois » qui écrit « des histoires pornographiques
».
Petite précision : si la vie de Freud vous
intéresse, j’ai fait une vidéo à ce sujet.
Trois essais sur la théorie sexuelle est
un des 3 livres phares de Freud (avec L’Interprétation
du rêve et la Psychopathologie de la vie
quotidienne, qui sont sortis quelques années
plus tôt). Ce livre suscite la controverse
non seulement parce qu'il traite de la sexualité,
mais surtout parce qu'il aborde la sexualité
des enfants (le 2ème essai du livre a pour
titre « La sexualité infantile », et le
3ème essai porte sur la puberté). Comme
le dira le disciple biographe de Freud Ernest
Jones, Trois essais sur la théorie sexuelle
est perçu comme « une attaque contre l’innocence
de l’enfance ». Ce livre deviendra néanmoins
une référence incontournable en psychologie
parce qu'il marque l'avènement d'une nouvelle
conception de la sexualité (une conception
qui sera très influente au XXe siècle et
qui contribuera même, estiment certains,
à la révolution culturelle des années 1960).
Que dire concernant la forme de ce livre ? Il
n’est pas énorme — environ 250 pages
— et il est divisé, comme le titre l’indique,
en 3 essais. Comme d’habitude avec Freud,
le propos est clair (surtout si on le compare
aux autres psychanalystes). Il balise le développement
de son exposé et il accompagne le lecteur.
Le texte est très subdivisé et les paragraphes
sont plutôt courts. Les phrases ne sont pas
interminables. Si le ton est scientifique
— Freud voulait imposer la psychanalyse
comme une science — le vocabulaire n’est
pas trop technique. Dans l’ensemble, le
style est agréable par rapport à ce qu’on
peut attendre.
Maintenant, quelles sont les idées essentielles
à retenir ?
Je vais vous résumer rapidement chaque essai.
Le premier parle des déviations sexuelles.
Freud commence par réfuter la croyance alors
largement répandue selon laquelle la sexualité
est essentiellement une fonction biologique
liée à la reproduction. Il affirme que la
sexualité est une force omniprésente, beaucoup
plus complexe, et qu’elle a une énorme
influence dans de nombreux aspects de la vie
humaine. En réalité, des comportements sexuels
dits « anormaux » sont assez communs. Et
dans les faits, la plupart des gens ont des
tendances pouvant être considérées comme
déviantes à un certain degré. Freud range
donc des formes de sexualité comme l'homosexualité,
le fétichisme, le masochisme ou le sadisme
sur le spectre normal de la sexualité humaine.
Enfin, dans ce premier essai, il élucide
l’influence de la sexualité dans la vie
humaine grâce à l’idée de pulsion sexuelle.
Il estime que les pulsions sexuelles peuvent
être sublimées ou réorientées, mais qu'elles
influencent toujours l’esprit humain de
manière significative.
Le deuxième essai porte, comme je vous l’ai
dit, sur la sexualité infantile. Freud bouscule
les idées reçues en affirmant que les enfants
ont une vie sexuelle active. Elle se manifesterait
à travers des pulsions érotiques présentes
dès le plus jeune âge. Mais ces pulsions
ne sont pas centrées sur la procréation
comme elles le sont chez l'adulte. Elles traversent
plusieurs stades de développement, qui correspondent
à des périodes où l'enfant tire du plaisir
de différentes parties du corps. Au « stade
oral » (de la naissance à environ 18 mois),
le plaisir est associé à la bouche (d’où
le nom). Au « stade anal » (18 mois à 3
ans), l'enfant prend plaisir à contrôler
ses sphincters. Enfin, le « stade phallique
» (3 à 6 ans) est centré sur les organes
génitaux. Freud suggère que les insatisfactions
qui surviennent à ces stades peuvent avoir
des répercussions sur le comportement et
la personnalité à l'âge adulte.
Enfin, le troisième essai du livre porte
sur la puberté, la période qui marque le
passage de l’enfance à l’adolescence,
au cours de laquelle les organes génitaux
deviennent aptes à la reproduction. Freud
explore la transformation des pulsions sexuelles
de l'enfance en la sexualité adulte. À ses
yeux, l'émergence de la forme définitive
de la sexualité est le facteur essentiel
des grandes transformations psychologiques
de la puberté. Deux évolutions de la libido,
l’énergie des pulsions sexuelles, sont
cruciales : première évolution, la libido
est réorientée vers les organes sexuels
(alors qu’elle était centrée sur diverses
parties du corps chez l’enfant) ; et seconde
évolution, la libido devient plus clairement
orientée vers des objets extérieurs, c'est-à-dire
vers d'autres personnes. Freud ajoute que
la puberté est également une période de
sublimation. Plutôt que d’être satisfaites
ou réprimées, certaines pulsions sexuelles
sont déviées ou transformées en activités
socialement acceptables, comme l'art ou le
travail intellectuel.
L’influence de ce livre dans la pensée
psychologique tient à 3 choses :
1. Il déstigmatise la sexualité. Freud y
défie ouvertement l’opinion populaire et
les préjugés en cours sur la sexualité.
Il la démystifie en l’abordant sous tous
ses aspects, ce qui ouvre la voie à une exploration
scientifique.
2. Le livre théorise la sexualité infantile.
Freud fait remonter la sexualité à une période
bien plus précoce qu’on ne l’avait pensé
jusqu’alors, et il avance que les expériences
sexuelles infantiles ont une grande influence
sur le développement psychologique.
3. Le livre fait partie des ouvrages fondateurs
de la psychanalyse, qui deviendra l’école
de pensée psychologique la plus influente
dans la culture occidentale au XXe siècle.
Trois essais sur la théorie sexuelle contribue
donc à imposer une nouvelle façon d’explorer
l’esprit humain, à travers les prismes
de la sexualité et de l’inconscient.
4ème référence : Psychology as the Behaviorist
Views It (1913), John Broadus Watson
Au début du XXe siècle, John Broadus Watson
est une star. La nouvelle école de pensée
psychologique qu’il a fondée, le « behaviorisme
» (« comportementalisme » en français),
domine la psychologie scientifique au point
que les psychologues disent dès 1920 que
tout le monde est devenu behavioriste. Watson
a une confiance inébranlable dans ses idées.
Il affirme notamment qu’elles sont un instrument
d’éducation très efficace. « Donnez-moi
une douzaine de nourrissons en bonne santé,
dit-il, et je vous garantis de former n’importe
lequel d’entre eux pour qu'il devienne médecin,
avocat, artiste, chef de commerce, et oui,
même mendiant et voleur ». Et comme Watson
est honnête, il applique ses théories sur
ses propres enfants. Résultat ? Le deuxième
enfant de son premier mariage fait une tentative
de suicide. Les deux enfants de son second
mariage font chacun une tentative de suicide.
Une de ses petites filles, elle aussi accablée
par de graves problèmes psychologiques, donne
l’explication suivante : « J’ai été
élevée selon les théories de mon grand-père
».
Psychology as the Behaviorist Views It (en
français « La psychologie telle que la conçoit
le behavioriste ») — ce texte est l'acte
de naissance de la psychologie behavioriste
(c’est pour ça qu’on l’appelle également
« Le manifeste du behaviorisme »). Il s’agit
à l’origine d’une conférence, dont le
texte sera publié sous la forme d’un article
en 1913. Watson fonde donc une nouvelle de
pensée psychologique à seulement 35 ans
(il était un surdoué, entré à l’université
à seulement 16 ans, devenu prof à seulement
30 ans, ce qui est d’autant plus impressionnant
que ses parents étaient de pauvres fermiers).
Concernant la forme, l’article (qui est
disponible gratuitement sur internet) est
rapide à lire : il fait environ 20 pages
au format livre. Le propos est moyennement
accessible. D’un côté, le style est formel
; les paragraphes sont trop longs ; les phrases
sont parfois longues et théoriques. De l’autre
côté, le style est aussi plutôt pragmatique,
à certains moments direct ; Watson essaie
d’accompagner son lecteur, et il est capable
d’écrire des phrases courtes et claires.
En conclusion, cet article est lisible pour
un amateur motivé… qui parle anglais.
Que retenir du fond de l’article, maintenant
?
Watson défend l’approche révolutionnaire
du behaviorisme. Il faut écarter l'analyse
de la conscience et des états mentaux internes
— l’approche prévalente dans la psychologie
de l’époque — au profit de l'étude des
comportements observables et mesurables. Au
sens strict, la notion de « comportement
» désigne une action manifeste, directement
observable, qui se distingue des phénomènes
psychiques « internes » (tels que les cognitions
et les affects). Un behavioriste refuse les
explications dites « mentalistes » parce
qu’elles se contentent d’invoquer des
entités mentales telles que des pulsions,
des complexes, ou encore l’Inconscient entendu
comme une entité à l’intérieur de la
personne. « Personne n’a touché une âme
», dit Watson.
Il avance deux arguments plus précis contre
l’idée de faire de la psychologie en étudiant
ce qu’il y a à l’intérieur de l’esprit.
Son premier argument, c’est que les méthodes
introspectives reposent sur des expériences
subjectives. Du coup, leurs résultats sont
invérifiables (en particulier, elles ne permettent
pas de produire l’accord entre plusieurs
observateurs). Par exemple, si on essaie d'étudier
la sensation de faim uniquement par l'introspection,
on obtiendrait probablement une multitude
de descriptions différentes, ce qui rend
difficile de comparer les résultats.
Watson assène un autre argument contre les
méthodes introspectives en psychologie : leurs
résultats n’ont aucune utilité pratique,
contrairement à ceux de la psychologie animale,
qui permettent de prévoir et donc de contrôler
les comportements des animaux en se passant
de l'introspection, de la conscience et du
langage. Par exemple, en récompensant un
chien avec une friandise chaque fois qu'il
s'assoit sur commande, on peut prévoir et
contrôler son comportement sans comprendre
ses pensées internes.
Watson en conclut que la psychologie behavioriste,
elle, est à la fois objective et utile en
se concentrant uniquement sur les comportements
qui peuvent être observés et mesurés. Son
ambition est de découvrir les lois universelles
qui régissent le comportement, qu'elles soient
applicables aux humains ou aux animaux. Comme
l’illustre la citation que j’ai lue au
début — dans laquelle Watson prétend pouvoir
élever un nourrisson pour en faire n’importe
quel professionnel — un médecin, un avocat,
un artiste, un entrepreneur, ou même un mendiant
et un voleur — cette citation révèle la
foi de Watson en la puissance du conditionnement.
Et cela présuppose que c’est surtout l’environnement,
plus que l’hérédité, qui façonne le
comportement humain.
Watson sera malheureusement discrédité par
sa vie privée — il est viré de l’université
Johns-Hopkins (située dans la banlieue de
Washington) lorsque sa femme publie les lettres
enflammées qu’il échangeait avec son assistante
— mais les idées de Psychology as the Behaviorist
Views It seront très influentes en psychologie.
En premier lieu, elles réduisent l’objet
de la psychologie. Elles ramènent l’homme
à sa condition animale, et plus fondamentalement,
elles disqualifient la séparation entre l’intérieur
(la vie de l’esprit) et l’extérieur de
l’être humain.
Ensuite, les idées de Psychology as the Behaviorist
Views It valorisent l’expérimentation,
car seuls les comportements observables ont
une valeur pour la psychologie. Les behavioristes
imaginent donc des expériences pour mesurer
le conditionnement. Par exemple, dans l'expérience
dite du « petit Albert » — une des plus
célèbres de Watson — le fondateur du behaviorisme
a réussi à conditionner un bébé de 9 mois
à craindre un rat blanc en faisant un bruit
fort à chaque fois qu’Albert touche le
rat.
Plus généralement, les recherches sur l’apprentissage
et sur les conditionnements se multiplient
avec la diffusion des idées de Watson. Des
applications de la psychologie behavioriste
se développent, telles la behavior therapy
(qui traite les troubles mentaux avec une
approche behavioriste) ou les pédagogies
behavioristes.
Enfin, le behaviorisme modifie en quelques
décennies la représentation de l’être
humain. L’homme n’est qu’un animal — certes
plus intelligent et plus complexe que les
autres, mais un animal. Burrhus Frederic Skinner,
qui est le dernier grand représentant du
behaviorisme, estime que cette vision de l’homme
s’est imposée parce qu’elle est en adéquation
avec l’idéologie matérialiste, utilitariste
et pragmatiste, propre au mode de vie américain.
5ème référence : Psychologie de l'inconscient
(1916), Carl Gustav Jung
Au tout début du XXe siècle, Carl Gustav
Jung est le disciple le plus célèbre de
Freud. Le fondateur de la psychanalyse trouve
Jung brillant, et il le voit comme son futur
successeur. Pendant plusieurs années, c’est
le grand amour intellectuel. Les deux hommes
peuvent rester des heures à échanger leurs
idées, à se séduire réciproquement. Et
le jeune Jung assure son maître qu’il adhère
à 100 % de sa théorie. Mais avec le temps,
il y a un hic : Jung demande et redemande
à Freud de définir précisément la libido
; or, Freud tourne autour du pot, il est incapable
de donner une réponse satisfaisante. Et puis
petit à petit, Jung se met à penser la même
chose que beaucoup de gens : Freud donne une
importance disproportionnée à la sexualité.
Ce livre, Psychologie de l'inconscient, naît
de leur divorce intellectuel en 1914. Il sert
à Jung à poser ce qui le différencie de
son ancien maître. Le disciple ne rejette
pas en bloc la psychanalyse freudienne, mais
il en abandonne une partie des notions fondamentales,
qui lui apparaissent en réalité bien fragiles.
Psychologie de l'inconscient est donc une
référence incontournable en psychologie
parce qu’il présente l’essentiel de la
pensée du psychanalyste qui a eu le plus
d’influence sur la culture occidentale après
Freud.
Concernant la forme, c’est plutôt un petit
livre (environ 200 pages). Il n’est pas
facile à lire, mais c’est probablement
le livre de Jung le plus accessible pour les
amateurs. La richesse du propos — qui mêle
psychologie, mythologie et symbolisme — la
densité et le détail demandent un effort
de lecture. D’un côté, le style d’exposition
est agréable ; de l’autre côté, le langage
est tout de même sophistiqué, avec une terminologie
spécialisée (mais difficile de faire autrement,
étant donné la profondeur de l’analyse).
Autre défaut de forme, Jung n’hésite pas
à écrire de longues phrases à la structure
complexe.
Que retenir du fond du livre, maintenant ?
Jung le divise en 8 chapitres. Dans les 3
premiers chapitres, il parle de la naissance
de la psychologie comme discipline médicale
(évolution dans laquelle s’insère la psychanalyse)
; il parle de la théorie de l’Éros de
Freud et de l’intérêt de la psychanalyse
pour traiter la névrose, qui est un trouble
mental causé par un conflit entre les instincts
naturels et les normes de la culture ; ensuite,
Jung critique le concept de « volonté de
puissance » de Nietzsche en lui reprochant
de refuser l’instinct animal (ce qui, d’après
Jung, explique les problèmes psychologiques
de Nietzsche lui-même).
Les chapitres 4 et 5 livrent des idées essentielles.
Dans le chapitre 4, Jung distingue les deux
attitudes de base présentes chez les individus,
l'introversion et l'extraversion (notions
qui sont entrées dans la psychologie populaire).
L'introversion implique une réserve naturelle
et une tendance à la méditation, tandis
que l'extraversion se caractérise par une
sociabilité naturelle et une facilité d'adaptation
aux autres et aux situations.
Jung approfondit ensuite l’idée d’inconscient
dans le chapitre 5. Il y a d’une part l’inconscient
individuel, une réserve de perceptions et
de souvenirs propres à chaque individu ; et
il y a d’autre part l’inconscient collectif,
qui contient des images universelles, ou « archétypes
». Les hommes ont tendance à utiliser,
à toutes les époques de l'Histoire et
en tout lieu, les mêmes modèles élémentaires
de comportement et de représentation, inscrits
dans la structure même du cerveau : ce sont
les archétypes. Il s’agit d’images archaïques
et universelles rencontrées avec une récurrence
remarquable dans les rêves, les croyances
religieuses, les mythes et les contes. En
pratique, lorsque les archétypes émergent
à la conscience à travers les rêves, ils
peuvent influencer le comportement de l’individu,
la manière dont il se comprend lui-même,
et le sens qu’il donne à son existence.
Dans les chapitres 6 à 8, Jung parle de sa
propre méthode d’analyse des rêves et
revient sur les archétypes, l’inconscient
et la méthode de guérison de l’esprit
de la psychanalyse. Il appelle sa méthode
d'analyse des rêves « synthétique » ou
« constructive » parce qu’elle vise à
donner un sens global au rêve plutôt que
d’en isoler certains éléments spécifiques.
Jung termine le livre en expliquant que l’inconscient,
bien que dangereux, est un guide précieux
pour l’individu — c’est pourquoi il
est crucial de maintenir le lien avec l’inconscient.
Psychologie de l'inconscient est important
dans la pensée psychologique parce qu’il
marque la naissance d’une nouvelle version
de la psychanalyse, la « psychologie analytique
». Son originalité réside dans l’étude
des relations entre les dimensions individuelle
et collective de l’esprit humain (Jung prend
par exemple en compte l’influence des mythes
et des traditions dans le façonnage des mentalités).
On appelle cela la « psychologie des profondeurs
».
L’influence de ce livre réside donc aussi
dans le fait qu’il élargit considérablement
l’objet de la psychologie (c’est l’influence
contraire de celle du behaviorisme). Comme
je vous l’ai dit, Jung est la 2ème « star
» de la psychanalyse. Or, il doit en partie
sa popularité dans la culture occidentale
au fait qu’il s’est intéressé à des
phénomènes propres aux nouvelles spiritualités
qui ont émergé à la fin des Trente Glorieuses
en Occident : la connexion spirituelle entre
les êtres humains, les synchronicités, et
même les OVNIS.
6ème référence : Conditioned Reflexes (1927),
Ivan Pavlov
Fils d’un prêtre de campagne, Ivan Pavlov
est un nationaliste conservateur. Sachant
cela, on se dit que l’URSS, ça ne va pas
être le paradis pour lui. Et pourtant, Lénine
(le premier chef de la Russie soviétique)
signe en 1921 un décret qui confère un traitement
exceptionnel à Pavlov (qui a alors 72 ans),
et qui crée également des instituts d’études
du conditionnement (notamment à Saint-Pétersbourg)
pour approfondir les travaux de Pavlov.
Comment expliquer ce traitement de faveur
? Eh bien, le psychologue jouit déjà d’une
grande notoriété. Il a été le premier
Russe à décrocher le prix Nobel de médecine
en 1904 pour ses travaux sur la digestion.
Et puis surtout, Lénine est conscient de
l’utilité politique des travaux sur le
conditionnement de Pavlov (et Lénine n’est
pas le seul : l’étude scientifique du conditionnement
intéresse également les Américains).
Pavlov a réalisé ces travaux sur le conditionnement
au tournant du XXe siècle, et il a publié
ses découvertes les plus célèbres au début
du siècle. Seulement, elles sont parues sous
forme de monographies dans des revues d’Europe
de l’Est que les Occidentaux avaient beaucoup
de mal à se procurer. C’est pour ça que
ce livre, Conditioned Reflexes (dont il n’existe
pas d’édition récente en français), paraît
une vingtaine d’années après les découvertes
de Pavlov. Il s’agit de la version écrite
étendue d’une série de conférences données
par le psychologue pour faire une synthèse
globale de ses expériences, de ses résultats,
et de la pensée psychologique qui en découle.
C’est donc la meilleure introduction au
travail de Pavlov. C’est évidemment une
référence incontournable parce qu’elle
introduit le concept de conditionnement, qui
est un des plus importants en psychologie.
Petite précision de vocabulaire : on parle
de conditionnement « classique » pour le
distinguer d’une autre forme de conditionnement,
le conditionnement dit « opérant ». Le
conditionnement classique consiste à associer
un réflexe à un stimulus artificiel (par
exemple, lorsqu'on sonne une cloche juste
avant de donner à manger à un chien, le
chien finit par saliver simplement en entendant
la cloche, même sans nourriture en vue).
Le conditionnement opérant se sert de récompenses
et de punitions pour apprendre un comportement
(par exemple, j’ai appris à mon chien à
se tenir debout en lui offrant de la nourriture
à chaque fois qu’il le faisait [à force,
j’avais l’impression qu’il savait marcher]).
Que dire de la forme de Conditioned Reflexes
?
Ce livre est plutôt long : plus de 400 pages.
Comme le texte est issu de conférences, le
ton est informel, ce qui est agréable. Les
phrases ne sont pas interminables, et Pavlov
nous guide dans le développement de son exposé
— mais les paragraphes sont parfois trop
longs. Pavlov s’exprime clairement — il
évite le jargon, vu qu’il vulgarise son
travail — mais il y a quand même pas mal
de termes techniques (donc il faut un bon
niveau d’anglais pour tout comprendre).
Toute la partie du livre qui relève du recueil
d'expérimentation, avec les schémas et les
tableaux, n’est pas passionnante pour l’amateur.
Maintenant, quel est l’essentiel à retenir
sur le fond ?
Pavlov souligne le manque de connaissances
sur le cerveau. Il en déduit que la physiologie,
l’étude des fonctions dans l’organisme
vivant, est plus utile que la psychologie
(Pavlov est lui-même médecin et physiologiste).
Il fait référence au philosophe français
Descartes, qui avait décrit les animaux comme
des machines réagissant à des stimuli environnementaux
pour atteindre un certain équilibre (c’est
la fameuse théorie de « l’animal-machine
»).
Pavlov évoque bien sûr ses célèbres expériences
sur les chiens. Elles sont un cas de sérendipité,
c’est-à-dire la faculté ou le fait d’exploiter
des résultats obtenus par hasard, dans l’histoire
des sciences. Pavlov a en effet l’attention
attirée par un fait banal, mais auquel personne
avant lui n’avait attaché d’importance
: les chiens de ses expériences se mettent
à saliver avant même que la nourriture soit
placée dans la gueule, lorsque les pas du
préparateur qui l’apporte se font entendre
dans le couloir. Comme cette activation prématurée
des glandes salivaires est un fait dérangeant,
Pavlov pourrait simplement faire déposer
la nourriture dans la salle d’expérience
avant d’y introduire le chien, ou encore
munir les pieds de son préparateur de chaussons
silencieux. Mais il saisit l’importance
et la signification du phénomène, qu’il
baptise « salivation psychique ».
Pavlov conclut que la salivation prématurée
du chien est une réponse apprise. En revanche,
la salivation à la présentation de la nourriture
est une réponse non apprise, instinctive.
Mais avec temps et la répétition des mêmes
actes, l’esprit du chien finit par associer
l’arrivée du préparateur avec la présentation
de la nourriture. Cette conclusion démontre
l’existence de l’apprentissage par conditionnement
: l’esprit associe un stimulus naturel (la
nourriture, par exemple) avec un stimulus
neutre (le bruit des pas, par exemple), et
ce faisant il apprend à répondre automatiquement
à un stimulus neutre.
Dans le dernier chapitre, Pavlov se penche
sur les applications de ses travaux chez les
humains. S’il est conscient de la complexité
supérieure du cerveau humain, il compare
certains phénomènes humains au conditionnement
de l’animal. Par exemple, la manière dont
les êtres humains sont formés, disciplinés
et enculturés — cela ressemble à la manière
dont les chiens sont dressés. Aux yeux de
Pavlov, l’homme et le chien ne diffèrent
que par le degré de complexité de leurs
réflexes conditionnés.
Comment résumer l’énorme influence de
ce livre en psychologie ?
Tout d’abord, il introduit le paradigme
du conditionnement. Cela signifie que le travail
de Pavlov a notamment posé les bases du behaviorisme,
dont je vous ai déjà parlé. Donc on peut
dire que la révolution de la pensée psychologique
qui a eu lieu au début du XXe siècle aux
États-Unis, puis plus largement en Occident,
cette révolution a commencé… en Russie.
Ça me rappelle une blague des biologistes
américains des années 1950 : lorsqu’ils
faisaient une découverte, ils disaient qu’elle
avait déjà été publiée dans un obscur
journal soviétique quelques années auparavant.
Autre dimension de l’influence de ce livre
en psychologie, l'approche expérimentale
rigoureuse décrite dans ses pages a contribué
à établir la psychologie comme une science
empirique. Après, les expériences de Pavlov
ont certes été très utiles, mais elles
sont un peu choquantes pour un amoureux des
chiens comme moi…
Enfin, autre dimension de son influence, ce
livre a également ouvert la voie à des applications
pratiques dans plusieurs domaines. Le conditionnement
classique sert par exemple dans la thérapie
comportementale, pour aider les patients à
surmonter les phobies et autres troubles anxieux.
Il sert aussi dans les méthodes d’enseignement
qui reposent sur l'apprentissage par association
(par exemple, apprendre de nouveaux mots d’une
langue étrangère en les associant à des
images) ; ou encore en marketing, pour influencer
les comportements du consommateur (par exemple,
certaines boutiques diffusent un parfum agréable
à leur entrée afin que, par association
avec le plaisir de l’odorat, l’acte d’entrer
dans le magasin devienne agréable en lui-même).
7ème référence : A Theory of Human Motivation
(1943), Abraham Maslow
L’adage médical dit que l’homme peut
survivre 3 minutes sans respirer, 3 jours
sans boire, et 30 jours sans manger. Cela
signifie que, dans l’absolu, l’homme accorde
plus d’importance à la respiration qu’à
la soif, et plus d’importance à la soif
qu’à la faim. Il existerait donc une hiérarchie
des besoins : il faut en satisfaire certains
avant les autres.
A Theory of Human Motivation est à l’origine
un article scientifique publié en 1943 dans
la revue de référence en psychologie, la
Psychological Review. Abraham Maslow est alors
un psychologue américain (fils d’émigrés
ukrainiens) de 35 ans qui est prof dans diverses
universités de New York. Son article deviendra
la référence incontournable sur le thème
de la motivation, c’est-à-dire les raisons
qui mettent en mouvement l’être humain
(le mot « motivation » vient du latin motus,
qui signifie « mouvement »). La théorie
de Maslow est si importante qu’il fait partie
du top 10 des psychologues les plus cités
au XXe siècle.
Concernant la forme, l’article fait une
vingtaine ou une trentaine de pages selon
l’édition. Le ton formel scientifique n’est
pas super agréable pour l’amateur, mais
ça reste lisible. Le propos est plutôt clair,
et le style de Maslow est pragmatique. Il
subdivise son texte pour aborder progressivement
l'ensemble des besoins humains qu'il identifie.
Après, certains paragraphes sont vraiment
longs pour un lecteur de 2023.
Quel est l’essentiel à retenir de cet article,
maintenant ?
Il est passé à la postérité pour ce qu’on
appelle la « pyramide de Maslow ». La pyramide
est un des meilleurs symboles, sinon le meilleur
symbole pour exprimer l’idée de hiérarchie,
c’est-à-dire une subordination de choses
en série. À partir des expériences cliniques
qu’il a menées au cours des années précédentes,
Maslow élabore une pyramide pour schématiser
la hiérarchie des motivations profondes de
l’homme.
La première chose à savoir pour comprendre
cette pyramide est que Maslow identifie chez
l’homme 5 groupes de besoins. Certains sont
plus évolués, d’autres plus primitifs.
Voici la hiérarchie détaillée de la pyramide
:
* l’individu doit d’abord satisfaire ses
besoins physiologiques qui sont nécessaires
à la survie (notamment respirer, boire, manger,
ou encore le maintien de l’équilibre des
constantes physiologiques comme la température)
;
* au niveau suivant, l’individu valorise
la sécurité dans ses diverses dimensions
(l’intégrité physique, la santé, ou encore
la sécurité financière) ;
Ensemble, les deux premiers niveaux de la
pyramide — les besoins physiologiques et
la sécurité — constituent ce qu’on appelle
les « besoins fondamentaux ».
* au troisième niveau, l’individu recherche
l’affection d’autrui : la famille, les
amis, la vie amoureuse, ou encore la communauté
satisfont ce besoin ;
* à l’avant-dernier niveau, l’individu
recherche la reconnaissance, c’est-à-dire
le fait que les autres pensent qu’il est
une personne de valeur (ce besoin peut être
satisfait par les résultats scolaires, le
sport d’équipe, plus généralement les
loisirs personnels, ou encore des activités
professionnelles) ;
* enfin, au cinquième et dernier niveau de
la pyramide de Maslow, l’individu cherche
à s’accomplir, ce que Maslow définit (de
manière assez vague) comme l’exploitation
complète du potentiel personnel.
Comment l’homme passe-t-il d’un niveau
de la pyramide au suivant ? Théoriquement,
un groupe de besoins ne se manifeste qu’une
fois que le précédent est satisfait. Mais
le passage d’un groupe au suivant est très
progressif. Maslow recommande de voir les
choses en pourcentages : par exemple, un homme
peut être satisfait à 70 % dans ses besoins
de sécurité, à 50 % dans ses besoins d’amour,
et à 40 % dans ses besoins d’estime. Autre
précision importante : dans les faits, la
progression n’est pas linéaire vers le
sommet de la pyramide. Comme la vie est imprévisible,
l’homme peut redescendre la pyramide (par
exemple s’il est contraint de sacrifier
sa sécurité pour se nourrir).
Maslow reconnaîtra lui-même les limites
de son modèle. La psychologie de la motivation
est en réalité bien plus complexe, c’est
pourquoi le mécanisme de la pyramide admet
beaucoup d’exceptions. Par exemple, les
hommes qui s’engagent comme volontaires
pour combattre avec l’armée ukrainienne
sacrifient leur sécurité pour une cause
qui a du sens à leurs yeux, c’est-à-dire
qu’ils sacrifient le bas de la pyramide
pour le haut. On a également reproché au
modèle de la pyramide d’entretenir la confusion
entre les besoins, qui sont essentiels à
la survie de l’organisme, et les désirs,
qui ne sont pas essentiels à la survie.
Quelle a été l’influence de A Theory of
Human Motivation en psychologie ?
Cet article a d’abord contribué à un changement
de paradigme. La pensée psychologique se
concentrait sur la pathologie (les maladies
mentales et les troubles de la personnalité).
Mais Maslow, lui, s’intéresse à ce que
peuvent faire les individus sains pour améliorer
leur vie. Ce nouveau paradigme s’incarne
dans le 5ème niveau de la pyramide, celui
de ce qu’on appelle « l’auto-actualisation
» (ou « actualisation de soi »), ce qui
signifie la réalisation, par l’action,
de son potentiel personnel. Cette nouvelle
vision de la motivation humaine s’inscrit
dans la transformation de la mentalité occidentale
au cours des Trente Glorieuses. Une fois ses
besoins matériels comblés par la société
de consommation, l’individu moderne se rend
compte que cela ne lui suffit pas, qu’il
aspire à quelque chose d’autre.
Cet article est également important parce
qu’il a donné naissance à deux nouvelles
écoles de la pensée psychologique : la psychologie
dite « humaniste », qui émerge dans les
années 1950 (Maslow en est le fondateur)
— la psychologie humaniste aide les gens
à améliorer leur existence à partir de
leur expérience subjective ; et puis la psychologie
dite « positive », qui émerge dans les
années 1990, étudie les aspects positifs
de l’expérience humaine (d’où le nom
de psychologie « positive »).
Enfin, cet article a ouvert la voie à beaucoup
d’applications pratiques. Il a notamment
servi dans le monde de l’entreprise pour
comprendre ce qui motive les employés. Les
dirigeants prennent davantage en compte le
besoin de reconnaissance et le besoin de sens.
Petite interruption parce que je me dis que
si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
8ème référence : Découvrir un sens à
sa vie grâce à la logothérapie (1946),
Viktor Frankl
À 37 ans, Viktor Frankl, un psychiatre autrichien
influencé par la psychanalyse, est déporté
avec sa famille dans un camp de concentration
de la Tchéquie actuelle, à 60km au nord
de Prague. Deux ans plus tard, il est envoyé
au sud de la Pologne, à Auschwitz, le camp
de concentration le plus connu et le plus
mortel du régime nazi. Et il constate quelque
chose d’étrange en observant les prisonniers
: ceux qui sont les plus actifs, et qui paraissent
donc les plus aptes à résister, meurent
paradoxalement les premiers ; en revanche,
ceux qui sont en apparence les plus faibles
résistent plus longtemps.
Comment l’expliquer ? Il donne la réponse
dans Découvrir un sens à sa vie grâce à
la logothérapie, qui sort un an après sa
libération d’Auschwitz en 1945. Ce livre
est une référence incontournable parce qu’il
inaugure une nouvelle orientation dans la
pensée psychologique, qu’on peut qualifier
de « spirituelle ». Autrement dit, il introduit
l’idée que ce qui est le plus important
dans le fonctionnement de l’esprit humain
n’est relatif ni à la matière ni aux instincts
biologiques. C’est l’expression « sens
de la vie » qui capture cette idée. Et comme
l’indique le titre du livre, la thèse de
Krankl fonde une nouvelle thérapie, baptisée
la « logothérapie », ce qui signifie étymologiquement
« la thérapie par le sens » (« sens » étant
une des traductions possibles du mot grec
« logos »).
Sur la forme, ce livre n’est pas énorme
(environ 200 pages). Il est divisé en deux
parties. Dans la première, Frankl raconte
son expérience de prisonnier de camp de concentration.
Cette partie est plus agréable à lire parce
que c’est une histoire biographique. Elle
est écrite sur le ton de la conversation,
avec des exemples concrets vécus qui rendent
le propos très accessible. Le style est clair,
il y a des phrases courtes. La seconde partie
du livre présente l’approche thérapeutique
de Frankl. Le style est certes plus technique,
plus sec, mais les explications sont quand
même claires. Frankl fait l’effort de donner
des exemples et il revient à son expérience
concentrationnaire. Ce livre est donc globalement
très accessible. Et c’est probablement
en partie grâce à cette qualité qu’il
est devenu un immense best-seller (16 millions
d’exemplaires vendus dans le monde), et
un des livres les plus influents aux États-Unis
toutes catégories confondues (certains disent
qu’il est dans le top 10).
Maintenant, que retenir du fond de ce livre
?
La première idée essentielle est l’effet
psychologique de l’expérience des camps
de concentration. Frankl décrit un processus
d'adaptation psychologique des détenus en
trois phases. Il y a tout d’abord un choc
initial qui peut se manifester par un déni
de réalité. À Auschwitz, par exemple, les
prisonniers qui arrivent dans le camp refusent
de croire en leur sort et continuent d'espérer
échapper à la mort certaine. Dans la deuxième
phase de l’adaptation psychologique, le
prisonnier est apathique. Les émotions s'émoussent,
et la survie prend le dessus sur toute autre
préoccupation. La raison de ce changement
est que la mort se banalise. L’adaptation
psychologique permet par exemple aux détenus
d’être capables de récupérer la nourriture
et les vêtements des morts pendant une épidémie
de typhus (ils ne ressentent plus de pitié
à la vue des corps). Enfin, seuls les prisonniers
les plus chanceux connaissent la troisième
phase. Libérés du camp, ils éprouvent un
mélange d’incrédulité et d’amertume.
Au début, ils ne parviennent pas à goûter
leur liberté ; ils sont incapables de ressentir
du plaisir ou de la joie.
La deuxième idée essentielle du livre est
celle qui fonde la logothérapie : la motivation
primordiale de l’être humain est la quête
de sens (et non pas le plaisir, comme le postule
la psychanalyse, ou le bien-être, comme le
postule l’utilitarisme). En pratique, si
une personne trouve un sens à ce qu’elle
fait au quotidien, alors elle a quelque chose
à anticiper avec impatience — et cela lui
donne la force de persévérer dans l’existence.
« Lorsqu'on trouve un sens aux événements
de sa vie, écrit Frankl, la souffrance diminue
et la santé mentale s'améliore. » Mais
si une personne n’a rien à anticiper, alors
elle s’enfonce dans un « vide existentiel
». Les nombreuses scènes terribles dont
il a été témoin dans les camps ont fait
réaliser à Frankl que c’étaient les prisonniers
qui parvenaient à préserver le sens de leur
vie qui étaient les plus résilients. L’autre
enseignement des scènes auxquelles il a assisté,
c’est l’importance de la vie intérieure.
Certains détenus parvenaient à s’extirper
de leur réalité brutale en se plongeant
dans leurs souvenirs heureux, en se remémorant
l’amour de leurs proches, ou même des choses
drôles. En effet, leur mémoire et leur imagination
étaient hors d’atteinte des gardes nazis.
Précision importante : pour Frankl, il n’y
a pas UN sens général de l’existence valable
pour tous ; bien au contraire, le sens de
la vie est propre à chacun, et aussi propre
à une situation et à un contexte. Le tout
est de le trouver.
Mais comment le trouver ?
On pense d’ordinaire qu’on sait quoi faire
une fois qu’on connaît le sens de sa vie,
mais Frankl défend l’idée inverse : le
sens naît des choix, des actions, et de la
responsabilité que l’homme ressent à l’égard
de ce qu’il fait. Par exemple, certains
détenus ont trouvé du sens en décidant
de contempler un coucher de soleil, un bel
oiseau, ou en décidant d’aider les plus
fragiles en leur donnant du pain. Ces choix
signifiaient qu’ils n’étaient pas vaincus,
et par conséquent qu’ils devaient continuer
de vivre. « Au lieu de se demander si la
vie avait un sens, écrit Frankl, il fallait
s'imaginer que c'était à nous de donner
un sens à la vie chaque jour et à chaque
heure. »
Dans le détail, il y a 3 voies pour donner
un sens à l’existence :
1. la voie de l’accomplissement, qui consiste
à créer quelque chose (comme une œuvre
d'art) ou à effectuer une tâche importante
;
2. la voie de l’amour, qui consiste à vivre
une expérience profonde et unique ;
3. la voie de la transcendance, qui consiste
à dépasser une situation douloureuse inévitable,
c’est-à-dire à trouver un sens à sa souffrance.
Comment expliquer l’influence de ce livre
dans la pensée psychologique ?
En premier lieu, il théorise une expérience
psychologique extrême qui a marqué l’histoire
du XXe siècle. Cela donne au propos de Frankl
une profondeur et une crédibilité particulières,
et elles sont d’autant plus particulières
que Frankl a lui-même vécu l’expérience
extrême de l’intérieur en étant détenu
dans des camps de concentration.
En deuxième lieu, Découvrir un sens à sa
vie grâce à la logothérapie a créé une
nouvelle école de pensée psychologique.
On dit que la logothérapie est la « troisième
école de Vienne », après la psychanalyse
de Freud qui part du principe que l’homme
recherche le plaisir, et la « psychologie
individuelle » d’Alfred Adler [un ancien
disciple de Freud] qui part du principe que
l’homme recherche la puissance (thèse inspirée
par le concept de volonté de puissance de
Nietzsche).
Enfin, dernière dimension de l’influence
de ce livre dans la pensée psychologique,
comme je l’ai dit au début, on peut dire
qu’il « spiritualise » la psychologie.
C’est l’influence inverse de celle du
behaviorisme. « Personne n’a touché une
âme », disait Watson — mais Frankl, lui,
réhabilite une forme de spiritualité. Si
sa perspective éloigne la psychologie des
standards les plus rigoureux de la science
moderne, elle influencera considérablement
les psychologues américains au cours des
Trente Glorieuses.
9ème référence : L’Art d’aimer (1956),
Erich Fromm
Les coachs en séduction qui ont commencé
à investir internet au début des années
2000 ont inventé un mot intéressant : « oneitis
» (O - N - E - I - T - I - S). « One », cela
signifie bien sûr « un/une », et cela renvoie
à l’idée qu’un homme essaie de séduire
une seule femme à l’exclusivité de toutes
les autres. Ensuite, en anglais, le suffixe
« -itis » est souvent utilisé en médecine
pour désigner une inflammation (par exemple,
« arthritis » [« arthrite » en français]
est une inflammation d'une ou plusieurs articulations).
Mais pour faire simple, le suffixe « -itis
» renvoie à l’idée de symptôme, de maladie.
Donc ce mot créé par les coachs en séduction
américains, « oneitis », désigne la fixation
intense et malsaine d’un homme sur une seule
femme. Il l’idéalise et fantasme au point
d’en oublier une vérité essentielle : son
épanouissement romantique n’est pas lié
à une femme en particulier ; bien au contraire,
des milliers de femmes peuvent le rendre heureux.
Mais lorsqu’il souffre de « oneitis », son
immaturité romantique a atteint le stade
d’une maladie.
Alors, Erich Fromm n’est pas coach en séduction
— il est psychanalyste. Et il ne s’adresse
pas uniquement aux hommes en mal de tendresse
féminine, mais à toutes les personnes qui
veulent s’épanouir par l’amour, sous
diverses formes. L’Art d’aimer (titre
identique à celui du manuel de séduction
d’Ovide, un des plus célèbres poètes
de l’Antiquité romaine) — L’Art d’aimer
d’Erich Fromm est la référence en psychologie
sur le thème de l’amour. Cela en fait un
ouvrage incontournable dans la discipline,
parce que l’amour est la préoccupation
primordiale des êtres humains.
Sur la forme, L’Art d’aimer est un petit
livre de moins de 200 pages. Fromm nous prévient
dans la préface que ce n’est pas un travail
académique : il dit qu’il va utiliser aussi
peu de termes techniques et de références
extérieures que possible. Il a beau être
un universitaire et un psychologue professionnel,
il s’adresse à l’homme ordinaire. Son
propos est donc particulièrement clair. Ses
paragraphes et ses phrases ne sont pas interminables
; il dynamise le propos avec des questions
; et il fait référence à l’expérience
de l’amour de l’homme ordinaire, ce qui
permet justement à cet homme ordinaire de
saisir l’intérêt pratique, pour lui, de
ce qu’il est en train de lire. Pas étonnant
que des millions d’exemplaires se soient
écoulés avec ce style efficace.
Maintenant, quelles sont les idées essentielles
de ce livre ?
Je vais vous les présenter dans un ordre
logique.
Il faut partir du constat de l’immaturité
de l’homme moderne par rapport à l’enjeu
de l’amour. Or, il n’est pas responsable
de cette immaturité. Sa conception de l’amour
est en partie le produit de l’influence
de la société. Et à cet égard, Fromm point
du doigt l’influence déplorable de la société
de consommation (la 3ème partie du livre
s’intitule d’ailleurs « L’amour et
sa désintégration dans la société occidentale
contemporaine »). Fromm estime que la société
de consommation donne aux individus une vision
superficielle de l’existence et les empêche
par là de former des connexions authentiques.
Ils se comportent en amour comme pour le reste,
en consommateurs. L’homme recherche une
femme qui a un ensemble de qualités valorisées
sur le marché de la personnalité, et la
femme fait de même. « Deux personnes tombent
amoureuses l’une de l’autre, écrit Fromm,
lorsqu’elles ont le sentiment d’avoir
trouvé le meilleur objet disponible sur le
marché. » Ainsi, la société capitaliste
a transformé l’amour en une marchandise.
Une autre source — plus profonde — de
l’immaturité romantique est l’idée de
la passivité. Nous disons que nous « tombons
» amoureux, et nous constatons les fluctuations
de notre sentiment de la même manière que
nous subissons les variations du climat. Or,
Fromm dit de l’amour ce qu’Aristote dit
du bonheur : ce n’est pas quelque chose
qui nous tombe dessus (contrairement à ce
que suggèrent des mythes tels que celui de
Cupidon, ou celui du philtre d’amour). Si
c’était le cas, alors l’individu n’aurait
aucune responsabilité dans son amour, et
le sentiment amoureux pourrait disparaître
aussi vite qu’il est apparu.
Mais qu’est-ce que l’amour, alors ? C’est
une manière spécifique de se lier à autrui.
C’est donc un acte, et non une expérience
subie (Fromm dit d’ailleurs que les gens
devraient se demander comment aimer plutôt
que se demander comment être aimé).
Et on arrive là à la deuxième idée essentielle
du livre : il y a plusieurs manières de se
lier à autrui, donc il y a plusieurs formes
d’amour grâce auxquelles l’homme peut
s’épanouir. Fromm explique cela par la
condition humaine : l’homme se sent fondamentalement
isolé, c’est pourquoi il cherche à s’unir
aux autres afin de surmonter l’anxiété
de la séparation.
Fromm distingue ensuite 5 formes d’amour
:
1. l’amour parental (auquel il consacre
une sous-partie complète) comprend l’amour
maternel, qui est inconditionnel, et l’amour
paternel qui, lui, doit être mérité ;
2. l'amour fraternel est l'amour égalitaire
entre frères et entre amis, un attachement
indépendant de toute attraction physique
ou romantique ;
3. l’amour érotique est un amour intense
et passionné où la connexion physique joue
un rôle central (les deux partenaires veulent
fusionner en une seule entité) ;
4. l’amour de soi ne consiste pas à être
égoïste ou égocentrique, mais à prendre
soin de soi, à se connaître, et à être
responsable (pour Fromm, l’amour de soi
est une condition préalable pour être capable
d’aimer autrui) ;
5. l’amour de Dieu est comparable à l’amour
pour le père : l’homme doit mériter cet
amour par son comportement, tel l’enfant
qui veut mériter l’amour de son père.
Une fois qu’on a diagnostiqué l’immaturité
romantique de la société de consommation
et qu’on comprend un peu mieux ce qu’est
l’amour, on est prêt pour apprendre l’art
de l’amour (ce qui est la principale idée
du livre). En amour, il faut, écrit Fromm,
« procéder de la même manière que pour
apprendre n’importe quel autre art, à savoir
la musique, la peinture, la charpenterie ou
l’art de la médecine ». Et comme avec
tout art, il y a deux phases : la première
consiste à assimiler un savoir théorique
; la seconde à assidûment mettre en pratique
la théorie. L’état d’esprit est également
crucial : il faut abandonner l’idéal romantique
où l’amour est un sentiment qui s’empare
de nous sans prévenir ; et il faut aussi
abandonner la mentalité consumériste dénoncée
par Fromm. Dans le détail, les principes
de l’art d’aimer sont de prendre conscience
de sa place dans la société ; de comprendre
qu'on s’enrichit soi-même en se tournant
vers l'autre ; et de comprendre que c'est
paradoxalement en s'aimant soi-même qu'on
se libère.
L’Art d’aimer n’est pas une référence
classique dans la psychologie académique,
mais il a été influent dans la pensée psychologique
au sens large. J’y vois deux raisons essentielles.
La première est que le livre introduit une
perspective unique sur l’amour (l’amour
comme un art, et non pas comme un sentiment).
D’ailleurs, l’idée de considérer une
chose commune comme un art a si bien marché
que l’éditeur de Fromm l’a reprise pour
d’autres sujets, ce qui a donné — en
anglais — The Art of Being et The Art of
Listening. La seconde raison de l’influence
du livre dans la pensée psychologique est
qu’il mêle la psychologie avec la sociologie
(Fromm, qui a étudié la sociologie avant
la psychanalyse [il a eu un doctorat en sociologie]
— Fromm étudie l’influence de la société
sur l’amour).
Ce livre a eu plus généralement une grande
influence dans la culture occidentale. C’est
un des livres les plus populaires sur le thème
de l’amour, malgré le fait que Fromm critique
et invite à dépasser l’idéal romantique
qui prédomine en Occident.
10ème référence : Une théorie de la dissonance
cognitive (1957), Leon Festinger
Cela fait longtemps que les hommes prédisent
la fin du monde, et Dieu soit loué, nous
n’y sommes pas encore. Dans l’essai intitulé
L’échec d’une prophétie, trois psychologues
— dont Leon Festinger — suivent les membres
d’une secte qui croyait que la Terre allait
être détruite par un déluge. Certains adeptes
en étaient tellement convaincus qu’ils
avaient abandonné leur maison et leur emploi
afin de se consacrer entièrement à la secte.
Lorsque le déluge ne s’est pas produit,
les fidèles n’ont pas tous réagi de la
même manière. Les moins engagés étaient
capables d’admettre qu’ils s’étaient
ridiculisés ; les plus engagés, en revanche,
ont échafaudé une interprétation en vertu
de laquelle ils avaient raison depuis le départ
(c’est grâce à leur foi que la Terre n’a
pas été détruite).
C’est à partir de cette expérience que
Leon Festinger a élaboré la théorie de
ce livre au titre transparent, Une théorie
de la dissonance cognitive. Il est incontournable
en psychologie parce qu’il fournit la théorie
de référence sur la question de la cohérence
de l’esprit humain, c’est-à-dire l’absence
de contradiction et d'étrangeté entre les
éléments qui se trouvent dans l’esprit
humain. La dissonance cognitive est devenue
un concept central de la psychologie sociale,
la branche qui étudie comment les hommes
s’influencent les uns les autres.
Sur la forme, Une théorie de la dissonance
cognitive fait environ 300 pages. Le style
de Leon Festinger est clair : son propos est
accessible pour l’amateur ; il y a peu de
termes techniques qui représentent une difficulté.
En revanche, je trouve que Festinger ne donne
pas assez d’exemples concrets alors qu’il
en existe une infinité (mais j’imagine
que son texte perdrait en crédibilité scientifique
s’il le rendait trop accessible…). Enfin,
le principal défaut du propos, c’est sa
faible densité, ou sa lenteur. Festinger
donne l’impression de tourner autour du
pot. Il dit en une page ce qu’il pourrait
dire en une phrase.
Maintenant, quel est l’essentiel à retenir
sur le fond ?
Leon Festinger élabore le concept de dissonance
cognitive pour expliquer le fait que les gens
ont besoin de maintenir une cohérence entre
leurs pensées, leurs sentiments et leurs
comportements. Il part du principe que l’esprit
humain ne peut pas tolérer la coexistence
d’idées incompatibles — c’est-à-dire
des idées contradictoires sur le plan logique
— dans la conscience. En pratique, c’est
souvent une croyance solidement ancrée qui
repousse les idées contraires. « Un homme
avec une conviction est un homme difficile
à changer, écrit Festinger. Dites-lui que
vous n’êtes pas d’accord et il se détourne.
Montrez-lui des faits ou des chiffres et il
remet en question vos sources. Faites appel
à la logique et il ne voit pas où vous voulez
en venir » (fin de la citation). La dissonance
cognitive peut résulter d’une contrainte
extérieure (lorsque l’individu est forcé
d’agir en contradiction avec ses propres
convictions), ou bien de la vie psychique
autonome de l’individu.
Dans son premier sens, l’idée de dissonance
qualifie deux sons qui ne vont pas ensemble
selon les règles de la composition musicale
(on parle par exemple d’un accord « dissonant
»). Le concept de « dissonance cognitive
» de Festinger signifie par extension que
deux éléments mentaux peuvent être incompatibles
(comme deux sons peuvent être incompatibles),
et que la tension entre ces deux éléments
mentaux engendre un inconfort psychologique.
Par exemple, si un individu souhaite améliorer
son état de santé, mais qu’en même temps
il ne souhaite pas faire l’effort nécessaire
à une activité physique, alors il peut ressentir
une culpabilité qui le déprime. La théorie
de Festinger signifie que c’est la coexistence
de deux désirs contradictoires qui engendre
le mal-être.
Un cas particulier important de cette théorie
est l’adaptation à l’échec. C’est
cette dimension du concept de dissonance cognitive
qui l’a rendu célèbre. La culture classique
contient de nombreux exemples du phénomène
d’adaptation psychologique à l’échec.
Par exemple, l’adage « les raisins sont
trop verts » tiré de la fable de La Fontaine
Le renard et les raisins signifie que l’homme
a tendance à dévaloriser a posteriori un
objet de désir qu’il n’a pas réussi
à conquérir. Dans la fable, le renard ne
parvient pas à attraper les raisins, donc
il prétend, pour rationaliser son échec,
que les raisins ne sont pas bons à manger.
Il résout par là la tension psychique en
transformant son échec (involontaire) en
une renonciation (volontaire). La justification
des actes passés est en effet une des principales
causes de la dissonance cognitive. L’homme
préfère s’autopersuader qu’il a pris
une bonne décision plutôt que de supporter
l’idée qu’il a pris une mauvaise décision.
D’après Festinger, l’esprit élabore
des solutions pour supprimer la tension entre
les éléments mentaux incompatibles. Pour
expliquer ce phénomène, il compare la dissonance
cognitive à la faim : « la dissonance cognitive,
écrit-il, conduit à une action orientée
vers la réduction de la dissonance, comme
la faim conduit à une action orientée vers
la réduction de la faim ».
Un autre cas particulier important de dissonance
cognitive est la résistance des croyances.
Prenons un individu qui s’est engagé à
respecter sa croyance. Si on lui présente
des preuves indéniables de la fausseté de
sa croyance, alors son esprit ne va probablement
pas s’adapter en abandonnant la croyance
; le plus souvent, son esprit va s’accrocher
à la croyance, et même au contraire être
encore plus convaincu de la vérité de cette
croyance. C’est ce qui s’est passé avec
la secte millénariste suivie par Festinger
quelques années avant l’écriture de ce
livre. Lorsque le déluge prévu ne s’est
pas produit, les membres les plus engagés
n’ont pas admis qu’ils avaient déliré
; ils se sont mis à croire que c’est grâce
à leur engagement spirituel que la Terre
n’a pas été détruite. Cette interprétation
a résolu la dissonance cognitive entre leur
engagement et l’inaccomplissement de la
prophétie.
Ce livre a eu une grande influence en psychologie.
La première raison est qu’il a mis en lumière
un phénomène universel de l’esprit humain
qui joue un rôle important dans la motivation.
La théorie de la dissonance cognitive a enrichi
la psychologie sociale et jeté les bases
de recherches futures dans cette branche.
Deuxième raison de l’influence de ce livre
en psychologie : sa théorie inspirera dans
les décennies suivantes un grand nombre de
théories relatives au Soi, à la régulation
émotionnelle, ou encore aux menaces. Troisième
et dernière raison, la théorie de la dissonance
cognitive est utile dans la psychologie appliquée,
en thérapie, dans l’éducation ou encore
dans la publicité. Par exemple, un thérapeute
peut aider un patient à arrêter de fumer
en mettant en évidence la contradiction entre
l'amour de la vie et le fait de fumer. Exemple
dans l’éducation : un prof peut stimuler
la pensée critique en présentant des informations
qui contredisent les croyances préexistantes
des étudiants. Enfin, exemple dans la publicité
: une marque connue pour des produits bas
de gamme peut mettre en avant une gamme premium,
et la dissonance qu’elle crée par là invitera
les consommateurs à revaloriser la marque.
11ème référence : Des jeux et des hommes
(1964), Éric Berne
Imaginez la scène : le mari a oublié de
sortir la poubelle. Sa femme le remarque,
et elle explose. Elle lui dit « Maintenant
je te tiens, espèce de salaud » (« Now
I got you son of a bitch »). C’est bien
sûr une réaction disproportionnée par rapport
à la banalité de l’incident. En réalité,
la femme attendait le faux pas pour exprimer
sa frustration accumulée.
C’est un exemple du « jeu » psychologique
le plus célèbre de ce livre, baptisé par
Éric Berne « Now I got you son of a bitch
» (en français, « Maintenant je te tiens,
espèce de salaud »). La métaphore du jeu
sert à désigner les interactions sociales
en mettant en évidence le fait qu’elles
ont souvent des motifs inavoués (lorsqu’on
joue, on adopte un rôle et on fait semblant).
C’est grâce à cette métaphore que Des
jeux et des hommes est considéré comme le
livre le plus original de la psychologie moderne.
Il est aussi le livre emblématique de l’analyse
transactionnelle, l’école de pensée psychologique
créée par Éric Berne dans les années 1950.
Mais c’est un autre livre paru 3 ans plus
tôt, au titre moins sexy, Analyse transactionnelle
et psychothérapie, qui a fondé l’école
de pensée psychologique de l’analyse transactionnelle.
Éric Berne avait déjà évoqué les jeux
de la vie sociale avec des exemples concrets
dans cet opus ; puis le public et ses propres
étudiants lui ont demandé la liste des jeux
— c’est comme ça qu’Éric Berne a eu
l’idée de ce livre.
Sur la forme, Des jeux et des hommes est un
petit livre d’un peu plus de 200 pages.
Comme Éric Berne résume sa théorie dans
la première partie, le propos n’est pas
très accessible — il y a beaucoup de termes
techniques que Berne ne prend pas la peine
de vulgariser. C’est la même chose pour
la troisième partie, qui présente de nouvelles
données cliniques et théoriques. C’est
la deuxième partie qui a rendu le livre célèbre.
Berne y décrit dans le détail les différents
« jeux » psychologiques que les gens jouent.
Il analyse des exemples concrets que beaucoup
de lecteurs rapportent facilement à leur
vie quotidienne (par exemple, le mari qui
oublie de sortir la poubelle est une situation
classique de la famille américaine de la
classe moyenne des années 1960).
Maintenant, quel est l’essentiel à retenir
du fond ?
Il y a d’abord la définition de l’analyse
transactionnelle, l’école de pensée psychologique
fondée par Éric Berne (dans la version anglaise,
ce livre est présenté comme « Le manuel
de base de l'analyse transactionnelle »). Comme
son nom l’indique, cette théorie conçoit
toute interaction humaine comme une transaction,
c’est-à-dire un échange où chacun envoie
et reçoit quelque chose. Il y a donc une
métaphore commerciale : les hommes échangeraient
des informations, des émotions, et des attitudes
comme des biens ou des services. Par exemple,
si je dis « Bonjour » à mon voisin et qu’il
me répond « Bonjour », notre interaction
constitue un échange équitable de reconnaissance
et de respect.
Mais comment expliquer qu’une transaction
se déroule d’une manière plutôt que d’une
autre ? Pour Berne, qui est psychanalyste,
le facteur déterminant est ce qu’il appelle
« l’État du Moi ». Un État du Moi est
un état d’esprit créé par un modèle
de comportement. Par exemple, si une personne
se replie et évite le contact visuel chaque
fois qu'elle se sent critiquée, ce comportement
révèle un État du Moi spécifique.
Berne distingue 3 catégories d’État du
Moi :
1. l’État « parent » est l’état d’esprit
adopté par imitation des parents ou d’une
figure éducative marquante ;
2. l’État « adulte » est l’état d’esprit
adopté par l’individu pour répondre à
ce qui se produit dans son environnement immédiat
;
3. l’État « enfant » est l’état d’esprit
qui se définit par le fait de revivre une
pensée, un sentiment ou une attitude éprouvés
lors de l’enfance.
Ces trois États du Moi sont les trois composantes
de la personnalité. Un individu est dans
un certain État du Moi dans une certaine
situation, et la transition d’un État à
un autre peut être très rapide. Par exemple,
une personne au volant de sa voiture se met
dans l’État « enfant » lorsqu’elle
chante avec la radio ; elle passe à l’État
« parent » lorsqu’elle suit les règles
de la route ; et elle adopte l’État « adulte
» en évaluant le trafic pour choisir le
meilleur itinéraire.
Le paradigme de l’analyse transactionnelle
permet à Éric Berne d’analyser les interactions
sociales comme des jeux. Il y a plein de jeux
de cette sorte dans la vie quotidienne, d’une
banale conversation aux relations intimes.
Mais les gens en sont rarement conscients.
Berne analyse dans le détail 36 jeux psychologiques,
classés sous diverses rubriques. Il y a d’abord
les « jeux vitaux », des schémas de comportement
qui imprègnent toute la vie d'une personne
; les « jeux conjugaux » que jouent les
partenaires insatisfaits ; les « jeux sexuels
» ; les « jeux de société » ; les « jeux
des bas-fonds », qui servent surtout à obtenir
des avantages matériels ; et enfin la rubrique
des « jeux du cabinet de consultation », joués
par les malades envers leurs médecins pour
éviter la guérison.
Voici les jeux précis les plus emblématiques
:
* Le « Maintenant je te tiens, espèce de
salaud » (« Now I got you son of a bitch
» en anglais), que j’ai déjà évoqué,
consiste à attendre que l'autre fasse une
petite erreur pour le punir sévèrement.
Par exemple, un employé commet une erreur
mineure, et son patron en profite pour le
réprimander violemment.
* Le « Si tu n’étais pas là » (« If
It Weren't For You » en anglais) consiste
à blâmer notre partenaire de ne pas nous
laisser réaliser ce que nous voulons. Par
exemple, une femme épouse un homme conservateur,
puis se plaint qu'elle ne peut pas poursuivre
une carrière à cause de lui. Berne estime
que la plupart des gens choisissent inconsciemment
des partenaires qui leur imposeront des limites.
En réalité, ils ont peur de prendre le risque
d’accomplir leur désir, et ils pourront
rationaliser leur inaction avec l’excuse
de leur partenaire.
* Le « Pourquoi ne pas — Oui, mais » (« Why
Don't You — Yes But » en anglais) consiste
à refuser toutes les pistes de solutions
après avoir posé un problème. Par exemple,
un ami se plaint de son travail, mais trouve
des excuses pour rejeter chaque proposition
de changement d'emploi. D’après Berne,
l’individu qui joue ce jeu ne veut pas des
solutions, mais de l’empathie. Il joue le
rôle de l’enfant et ceux qui proposent
des solutions endossent le rôle de l’adulte.
* Le « Je ne fais qu’essayer de t’aider
» (« I'm Only Trying to Help You » en anglais)
consiste à offrir de l’aide à quelqu’un
tout en sabotant ses efforts. Par exemple,
une mère prétend aider sa fille à perdre
du poids, mais en même temps elle lui sert
constamment des aliments très caloriques.
À quoi bon connaître et détecter ces « jeux
» ? C’est le même principe que celui du
traitement psychanalytique : en prenant conscience
de ce qu’il se cache à lui-même, l’homme
fait disparaître les symptômes du secret.
Berne dit donc que prendre conscience des
« jeux » permet de neutraliser leurs effets
destructeurs dans les relations humaines.
Des jeux et des hommes a été très influent
en psychologie pour 3 raisons principales
:
1. Sur le plan de la théorie, il donne de
l’importance une nouvelle école de pensée
psychologique, l’analyse transactionnelle.
Le nouveau paradigme de Berne a apporté une
perspective fraîche en psychologie.
2. Sur le plan de la pratique, ce livre crédibilise
la thérapie de l’analyse transactionnelle.
Berne montre comment la thérapie qu’il
a créée permet d’identifier et de démanteler
les « jeux » destructeurs dans les relations
humaines.
3. Enfin, ce livre démocratise la psychologie.
En effet, il a été un énorme best-seller,
vendu à plus de 5 millions d’exemplaires
dans le monde. Il est un des premiers livres
de ce que les Américains appellent la « pop
psychology », qu’on peut définir comme
la transposition de la pensée psychologique
dans la vie quotidienne.
12ème référence : La psychologie de l’enfant
(1966), Jean Piaget
A priori, on se dit qu’il n’y a pas plus
éloigné que la physique quantique et la
psychologie. On peut même imaginer que les
physiciens ne prennent pas les psychologues
au sérieux ; qu’ils ne les considèrent
pas comme de véritables scientifiques. Et
pourtant Einstein s’intéressait aux idées
de Jean Piaget. Ils étaient tous les deux
profs en Suisse, et ils ont eu plusieurs occasions
de se rencontrer. La légende raconte même
que c’est Einstein — qui voyait de profondes
intuitions de physique dans le monde enfantin
— il paraît que c’est Einstein qui aurait
encouragé Jean Piaget à étudier la conception
du monde physique chez l’enfant.
Ce livre, La psychologie de l’enfant, est
le bilan des travaux de Piaget. Avec sa collègue
de longue date, la psychologue suisse Bärbel
Inhelder, ils présentent la pensée psychologique
qu'ils ont élaborée au cours des quarante
dernières années. Leur synthèse complète
retrace les étapes du développement cognitif
de l'enfant. Ce livre est une référence
incontournable parce qu’il fonde la psychologie
dite « du développement ». Cette branche
était autrefois confondue avec la psychologie
de l’enfant, c’est-à-dire qu’elle se
limitait à la phase de croissance physique
de l’organisme de l’être humain — mais
les psychologues s’intéressent aujourd’hui
aux phases suivantes, jusqu’à la vieillesse
(qui concerne une part croissante de la population
dans les sociétés modernes).
Concernant la forme, La psychologie de l’enfant
est un petit livre de 150 pages. Après, le
propos n’est pas toujours très accessible.
Le vocabulaire est parfois très technique,
et le ton impersonnel est globalement austère.
Les références aux travaux scientifiques
peuvent également intimider le lecteur amateur.
En revanche, la subdivision du texte en chapitres
et en sous-parties pas très longues facilite
la lecture.
Quoi retenir sur le fond, maintenant ?
La pensée de Piaget repose tout d’abord
sur une certaine conception de l’intelligence.
Cette conception dit que les pensées et les
opérations mentales se construisent de la
naissance à l’âge adulte dans le cadre
de l’interaction entre l’individu et son
environnement (ou, dans le langage de la biologie,
entre l’organisme et son milieu). Au cours
de l’enfance, en particulier, l’individu
agit sur les objets qui l’entourent (par
l’exploration, par la manipulation, et par
l’« expérimentation »), ce qui signifie
qu’il n’apprend pas de manière passive.
La finalité du développement de l’intelligence
est que l’individu dispose d’une compétence
cognitive unifiée qui serve son adaptation
biologique et psychologique à l’environnement.
Dans le détail, le développement de l’intelligence
passe par une série d'étapes reliées entre
elles : c’est la fameuse théorie des stades
de l’intelligence de Piaget (parfois qualifiée
de « modèle de l’escalier », chaque marche
symbolisant un grand progrès).
Cette théorie distingue 3 stades :
1. le stade dit « sensori-moteur » chez
le bébé (0-2 ans) ;
2. le stade des opérations concrètes chez
l'enfant (2-12 ans) ;
3. le stade des opérations formelles chez
l'adolescent (12-16 ans).
Cette théorie est dite « constructiviste
» parce qu’elle combine l’empirisme — position
selon laquelle tout provient de l’expérience
— et l’innéisme — position selon laquelle
les facultés intellectuelles de l’être
humain sont déjà présentes à la naissance.
Je vous explique rapidement chaque stade.
Je commence par le développement du bébé.
Comme l’indique le nom du stade « sensori-moteur
», de 0 à 2 ans, l’être humain interprète
le monde qui l’entoure sur la base de ses
sens et de ses actions. Dès la naissance,
et à partir de ses réflexes initiaux (comme
la succion du sein de sa mère), le bébé
apprend certaines règles sur le fonctionnement
du monde physique et sur sa capacité à agir
dessus. Par exemple, le nouveau-né découvre
vers 8 mois que, quand un objet (disons, son
nounours) disparaît de sa vue (caché derrière
un coussin sur le canapé), cet objet continue
néanmoins d’exister. Ce qui lui permet
de comprendre cela, c’est qu’il peut par
ses actions écarter le coussin qui cache
l’objet, puis l’attraper pour le ramener
à lui. Cette expérience que Piaget fait
avec ses propres enfants met en évidence
la découverte, par l’enfant, d’un principe
fondamental de la construction du réel, ce
qu’on appelle « la permanence de l’objet
» (ce qui vaut pour le nounours vaudra pour
tous les objets du monde).
Je passe au développement de l’enfant (entendu
au sens strict).
Selon Piaget, l’enfant se détache de l'action
immédiate à 2 ans. Il se met à intérioriser
et à combiner ce qu'il a appris au stade
sensori-moteur : les actions (réelles) deviennent
des opérations mentales. L’intelligence
de l’enfant devient « symbolique » ou
« représentative » (c’est-à-dire douée
de représentation mentale). En particulier,
le dessin et la parole, qui permettent à
l’enfant de décrire ou de représenter
des événements vécus, connaissent une extraordinaire
évolution, jusqu’à l’art et à la littérature.
Piaget subdivise l’évolution de l’enfant
en 2 sous-stades : de 2 à 7 ans, l’esprit
de l’enfant se prépare à ses nouvelles
capacités ; de 7 à 12 ans, il les met véritablement
en place. L’âge fatidique est donc 7 ans.
La mutation importante est, selon Piaget,
que l’intelligence de l’enfant devient
flexible. Il devient capable de simuler le
réel par la seule pensée. Par exemple, il
imagine l’annulation d’une action.
Je passe enfin au développement de l’adolescent.
À 12 ans commence le stade des opérations
formelles. Au stade précédent, l’enfant
se servait de son intelligence pour concevoir
et exécuter des opérations concrètes, c’est-à-dire
des opérations dans le monde matériel, à
l’extérieur de l’esprit, et perceptibles
par les sens. Désormais, l’enfant se sert
de son intelligence pour concevoir et exécuter
des opérations abstraites, c’est-à-dire
des opérations qui se déroulent à l’intérieur
de l’esprit.
Plus précisément, l’adolescent devient
capable de raisonner sur des propositions
logiques, des idées, et des hypothèses (c'est
ce que les scientifiques appellent le « raisonnement
hypothético-déductif »). Piaget souligne
que cette révolution cognitive renverse le
rapport entre la pensée et la réalité extérieure
: « Avant l'adolescence, écrit-il, le possible
est un cas particulier du réel, après c'est
le réel qui devient un cas particulier du
possible ! » Cette évolution de l’intelligence
humaine explique que l'adolescent a tendance
à s’opposer au système en place en adhérant
à de grands idéaux. Il découvre que lorsque
son cerveau se met en « mode hypothético-déductif
», il peut élaborer des théories pour « refaire
le monde » — et que tout est possible dans
le monde des idées.
Comment résumer l’influence de ce livre
en psychologie ?
On peut distinguer 3 facteurs d’influence
:
1. La psychologie de l’enfant est la synthèse
et l’acte de fondation d’une nouvelle
école de pensée psychologique, la psychologie
du développement.
2. Piaget est un précurseur de la psychologie
cognitive, une nouvelle école de pensée
psychologique qui étudie la manière dont
le cerveau traite l'information, et qui devient
dominante à partir des années 1960. En effet,
Piaget s’intéresse aux processus mentaux
internes, alors négligés par le behaviorisme.
3. Ce livre aura une influence sur l’expérimentation.
En effet, Piaget mène une large enquête
empirique à travers le développement de
l’enfant. Comme il n’est pas possible
de mener des expériences de laboratoire sur
des bébés, il s’inspire de l’éthologie,
la science qui étudie l’animal dans son
milieu naturel. Piaget imagine aussi des situations
expérimentales très ingénieuses (dites
tâches « piagétiennes ») — des expérimentations
qui seront reprises, contestées et améliorées
par les générations suivantes de psychologues
de l’enfant.
Enfin, ce livre qui a été traduit en 22
langues et qui a eu des millions de lecteurs,
a aussi transformé la vision de l’enfance.
Piaget montre que l’enfant est acteur de
son propre développement : il apprend en
interagissant avec son environnement, développant
ainsi son intelligence par l’expérience.
Comme Rousseau dans L’Émile (le livre de
philosophie le plus célèbre sur l’éducation),
Piaget conçoit l’enfance comme une période
unique et précieuse dans le développement
humain, nécessitant une compréhension et
une attention spécifiques. D’ailleurs,
à l’université de Genève, Piaget mène
ses travaux au sein de l’Institut Jean-Jacques-Rousseau,
baptisé ainsi en référence à L’Émile
de Rousseau.
13ème référence : Cognitive Psychology
(1967), Ulric Neisser
Il suffit parfois d’une seule rencontre,
d’une seule personne, d’une seule influence
pour changer le cours d’un destin. À la
fin des années 1940, Ulric Neisser, le fils
d’immigrés allemands qui ont fui le nazisme,
entre à Harvard pour faire de la physique.
Mais il y rencontre le prof de psychologie
George Miller. Ce dernier lui parle de nouvelles
théories qui comparent l’esprit humain
à un ordinateur, en termes de traitement
de l'information et de stockage en mémoire.
Intéressé, le jeune Neisser abandonne la
physique.
Vingt ans plus tard (environ) paraît Cognitive
Psychology (« La psychologie cognitive » en
français). Ce livre de 1967 est considéré
comme l'acte de naissance de la psychologie
cognitive, l’école de pensée psychologique
qui étudie la manière dont le cerveau traite
l'information. Cela fait d’Ulric Neisser
« le père » de cette nouvelle école. Premier
ouvrage à donner une vue d’ensemble exhaustive
et accessible de la psychologie cognitive,
Cognitive Psychology en est donc le premier
véritable manuel.
Sur le plan de la forme, c’est un livre
d’environ 350 pages. Neisser définit la
psychologie cognitive dans le chapitre introductif,
intitulé « L’approche cognitive » ; puis
il structure la suite du livre en fonction
de cette définition : il suit la réception
de l’information des stimuli par les organes
des sens ; les nombreuses transformations
et reconstructions de l’information ; et
enfin son éventuelle utilisation dans la
mémoire et la pensée. La 2ème partie du
livre (après l’introduction) parle de la
cognition visuelle (Neisser connaît bien
le sujet parce qu’il a beaucoup travaillé
sur les processus visuels) ; la 3ème partie
du livre parle de la cognition auditive ; enfin,
la 4ème partie est consacrée aux « processus
mentaux supérieurs » que sont la mémoire
et la pensée.
Le propos est plutôt clair. Neisser sait
accompagner le lecteur dans le développement
de son propos et évoquer des idées complexes
d’une manière plutôt accessible. Certains
paragraphes sont un peu longs, mais d’autres
sont courts — c’est pareil pour les phrases.
Le style est globalement pragmatique. Après,
le détail des expériences et de la théorie
n’est pas passionnant pour le lecteur amateur.
Maintenant, quel est l’essentiel à retenir
du contenu du livre ?
Tout d’abord, Neisser critique le behaviorisme,
la doctrine psychologique qui dominait au
cours de la première moitié du XXe siècle.
Les behavioristes se concentraient sur les
réactions observables, et laissaient donc
de côté l'étude des processus mentaux internes,
considérés comme inaccessibles (Watson,
le fondateur du behaviorisme, a fameusement
dit « Personne n’a touché une âme »). Neisser
est en désaccord avec cette approche restrictive.
En particulier, il rejette l'idée que le
comportement humain se résume à des processus
de conditionnement. Il trouve que les méthodes
behavioristes limitent le champ d’étude
de la psychologie, et qu’en cela elles ne
permettent pas de comprendre pleinement le
fonctionnement de l'esprit humain. Il déclare
carrément dans Cognitive Psychology qu'il
est temps de quitter le paradigme behavioriste.
Le nouveau paradigme pour lequel il plaide
repose sur le concept de cognition. La cognition
englobe les activités des organismes qui
contribuent à l'accroissement, au maintien
et à l'utilisation des connaissances. Cela
comprend des processus comme la perception,
la mémoire, la représentation symbolique,
la résolution de problèmes, et le langage
; mais cela exclut les émotions, les motivations,
et les affects. Par exemple, lorsque vous
entrez dans une pièce éclairée, vos yeux
captent la lumière et votre cerveau interprète
les formes et les couleurs pour vous permettre
de reconnaître les objets qui vous entourent,
comme un fauteuil ou une table. C’est un
acte de cognition visuelle. Neisser définit
plus précisément la cognition comme « l'ensemble
des processus par lesquels l'entrée sensorielle
est transformée, réduite, élaborée, stockée,
récupérée et utilisée ». Le concept de
cognition donne naissance à de nouvelles
disciplines intellectuelles (on parle souvent
des « sciences cognitives »), dont la psychologie
cognitive, qui étudie la façon dont le cerveau
traite l'information. C’est une manière
inédite d’étudier l’esprit humain.
Et comme je vous l’ai dit au début, cette
manière inédite d’étudier l’esprit
humain est inspirée par la comparaison avec
l’informatique. Les ordinateurs existent
depuis les années 1940 dans les sociétés
occidentales, mais leur usage ne se répand
que dans les années 1950 et 1960 (notamment
dans les entreprises, les universités, et
d'autres institutions) grâce à la miniaturisation
des composants électroniques et aux progrès
dans la programmation. Or, les psychologues
se rendent compte qu’il y a des similitudes
importantes entre la manière dont un ordinateur
traite l’information et le fonctionnement
de l’esprit humain. « Le parallèle familier
entre l’homme et l’ordinateur, écrit
Neisser, est une analogie adéquate à bien
des égards. » Il reconnaît que le fonctionnement
de l’esprit humain ne se résume pas à
celui d’un ordinateur — mais il insiste
sur le fait que la métaphore informatique
est un outil essentiel pour comprendre les
mécanismes de la pensée humaine. Neisser
précise également que la comparaison avec
l’ordinateur ne concerne pas les détails
matériels. Filant la métaphore, il dit que
le but de la psychologie cognitive est uniquement
de comprendre le « programme », c'est-à-dire
le fonctionnement de l'esprit — la psychologie
cognitive porte sur le software, pas sur le
hardware.
Mais comment la métaphore informatique sert-elle
concrètement ?
Elle permet notamment de modéliser le traitement
de l’information par l’esprit humain en
supposant qu’il traite l'information selon
une série d'étapes similaire à celle que
suit un ordinateur. Ces étapes comprennent
l'entrée, où les personnes reçoivent et
codent l'information ; le stockage, où l'information
est transformée et stockée en mémoire à
long terme ; et enfin la sortie, où une réponse
appropriée est produite. Par exemple, lors
de la préparation d'un repas, vous sentez
une odeur de brûlé — c’est l’entrée
de l’information. Alors, grâce au stockage
de l’information, votre cerveau associe
cette odeur à un aliment en train de brûler
et comprend qu'il faut agir. La sortie de
l’information, c’est votre réaction appropriée
: vous éteignez rapidement la cuisinière
et retirez la nourriture brûlée.
Ce livre a eu une influence majeure dans la
pensée psychologique. La première dimension
de cette influence c’est, comme je l’ai
déjà dit, la fondation d’une nouvelle
école de pensée psychologique. Seulement,
pas n’importe quelle école : l’école
qui prend la place de l’école behavioriste
comme paradigme dominant dans la psychologie
scientifique. Cognitive Psychology marque
donc une « révolution scientifique » au
sens de Thomas Kuhn (c'est-à-dire un changement
fondamental dans la manière dont les psychologues
perçoivent et étudient le monde). Ce livre
a inspiré de nombreux étudiants à choisir
la voie de la psychologie, et certains des
psychologues contemporains les plus reconnus
citent ce livre comme origine de leur carrière.
Enfin, la troisième dimension de l’influence
de ce livre concerne l’expérimentation.
Neisser a prôné la recherche cognitive dite
« écologique », c’est-à-dire dans des
contextes réels où les hommes se servent
de leur mémoire, de leur perception et de
leur attention (plutôt que dans l’environnement
contrôlé du laboratoire).
14ème référence : Learned Helplessness
(1972), Martin Seligman
Un chien peut tout à fait être dépressif.
Donc mener des expériences avec ces créatures
est un bon moyen d’étudier la dépression
(même si ce qu’on leur fait subir touche
une corde sensible chez les amoureux des chiens
comme moi). Par exemple, les psychologues
Martin Seligman et Steven Maier conditionnent
des chiens à anticiper un choc électrique
après avoir entendu un son. Ils placent ensuite
les pauvres bêtes sur une surface dont seule
une partie est électrifiée (ils peuvent
éviter la douleur en sautant une petite barrière
pour arriver sur la partie sécurisée). Et
là, résultat surprenant, les chiens ne tentent
même pas de s’échapper en allant sur la
surface non électrifiée.
Ce phénomène découvert par accident à
la fin des années 1960 donne naissance à
un nouveau concept, l’« impuissance apprise
». Le psychologue américain Martin Seligman
théorise ce nouveau concept dans un article
publié en 1972 dans l’Annual Review of
Medicine, une publication annuelle prestigieuse
qui rassemble des articles résumant les dernières
recherches et tendances dans le domaine médical.
Cet article est une référence incontournable
en psychologie parce qu'il présente la découverte
d'un mécanisme fondamental dans la compréhension
de la dépression.
Sur la forme, c’est rapide à lire (l’article
ne fait que 5 pages et il est disponible gratuitement
sur le site de l’Annual Review of Medicine).
Certains paragraphes sont un peu longs, mais
le propos est très accessible. Le style est
globalement direct, pragmatique. Seligman
emploie très peu de termes techniques. Par
exemple, sa description des expériences est
claire : je vois bien en imagination le comportement
du pauvre chien, au point de ressentir de
la pitié. Le ton est toutefois impersonnel
— mais c’est normal dans ce type de publication.
Que retenir du fond, maintenant ?
Les psychologues expérimentaux s'intéressent
généralement aux comportements des animaux
et des hommes face à des récompenses et
des punitions qu'ils peuvent contrôler. Mais
dans la nature, il y a aussi des événements
incontrôlables.
Seligman présente la notion d'impuissance
apprise comme une réaction passive face à
de tels événements incontrôlables. Les
organismes, y compris les êtres humains,
peuvent devenir passifs et stressés lorsqu'ils
sont confrontés à des situations où leurs
actions n'ont aucun effet. Seligman illustre
ce phénomène avec la fameuse expérience
sur les chiens. Comme je vous l’ai dit au
début, les chiens ayant déjà subi des chocs
inévitables n'ont pas tenté d'échapper
à la douleur dans la nouvelle situation où
c’était possible. Cela signifie que leur
passivité est apprise. « Le chien, écrit
Seligman, semble abandonner et accepte passivement
le choc. Il continue à échouer à faire
des mouvements d'évasion et subit autant
de chocs que l'expérimentateur choisit d'administrer
» (c’est moi qui ai traduit).
Cette impuissance apprise affecte précisément
la capacité d’apprendre. Ainsi, les sujets
qui ont été placés dans des situations
impossibles à éviter ont ensuite du mal
à comprendre que leurs actions peuvent avoir
un effet dans de nouvelles situations. Seligman
met en évidence cet effet avec une autre
expérience sur des rats (qui suit le même
principe que l’expérience avec les chiens).
Les rongeurs qui ont subi des chocs inévitables
perdent la capacité d’apprendre à éviter
les chocs dans une nouvelle situation.
Seligman passe des expériences sur les animaux
aux hommes. Il pense que l'impuissance apprise
peut être un mécanisme sous-jacent de la
dépression. Les chiens qui ont subi des chocs
inévitables développent une attente cognitive
selon laquelle rien de ce qu’ils font ne
peut arrêter les chocs. Or, cela se manifeste
par des symptômes similaires à ceux de la
dépression chronique. Certes, admet Seligman,
l’impuissance apprise n’est pas l’unique
cause des troubles de la dépression chronique.
Mais lorsqu’elle s’y surajoute, elle les
exacerbe. Et l’impuissance apprise peut
se développer tôt dans l’esprit humain.
C’est par exemple le cas chez les enfants
élevés dans des institutions, parce que
leur dépendance à l’égard de l’institution
leur apprend que leur sort n’est pas entre
leurs mains.
Maintenant, le lien entre l’impuissance
apprise et la dépression suggère-t-il des
pistes de solutions ?
La fin de l’article évoque des applications
thérapeutiques. Seligman pense qu’on peut
combattre l'impuissance apprise en aidant
les individus à reconnaître et à changer
leurs croyances sur le caractère inévitable
des événements. Dans les expériences sur
les chiens, Seligman et son partenaire ont
trouvé une solution pour sortir les bêtes
de leur impuissance apprise : ils leur ont
simplement appris à éviter le choc électrique.
Seligman baptise cette solution la « thérapie
directive ». Il écrit : « quand la "thérapie
directive" est utilisée […], tous les chiens
commencent finalement à répondre d’eux-mêmes.
La récupération de l’impuissance est complète
et durable ». Cette solution suggère qu’une
intervention extérieure est nécessaire pour
combattre la dépression. Il faudrait apprendre
à l’individu déprimé qu’il n’est
pas impuissant en lui faisant connaître une
expérience positive. Martin Seligman appelle
cela « l’optimisme acquis ».
Cet article a été très influent en psychologie.
En effet, il met en évidence un mécanisme
fondamental de la dépression, une maladie
psychologique majeure dans les sociétés
de consommation modernes. Ensuite, cet article
a inspiré aux thérapeutes de nouvelles stratégies
pour traiter la dépression, mais aussi des
problèmes d’apprentissage. Par exemple,
si un élève répète qu’il est nul en
mathématiques, le prof a intérêt à souligner
les causes spécifiques de ses difficultés,
comme le fait qu’il ne maîtrise pas tel
chapitre ou tel théorème. Cela implante
dans son esprit l’idée qu’il a le pouvoir
de sortir de son échec. Enfin, l’article
— et plus particulièrement l’idée de
l’optimisme acquis (par une intervention
extérieure) — l’article est également
à l’origine d’une nouvelle branche de
la psychologie, la « psychologie positive
», dont Martin Seligman est considéré comme
le père fondateur. Comme je vous l’ai dit
en parlant de la 7ème référence, cette
nouvelle branche prolonge la psychologie « humaniste
» fondée par Maslow dans les années 1950.
Vous aimez les gros manuels ?
Je sais bien, c’est pas une partie de plaisir.
Mais comment faire si vous voulez découvrir
les idées d’Aristote, par exemple ?
Eh bien allez sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Vous tapez « Aristote » dans la barre de
recherche, et vous avez les synthèses, des
synthèses très claires des meilleures idées
d’Aristote.
Rédigées avec amour et beaucoup de café,
par votre serviteur.
Et comme le nom l’indique, 1000 idées de
culture générale ce n’est pas que de la
philo.
Vous trouverez aussi les meilleures idées
en économie, en littérature, en histoire,
en science politique, en psychologie, etc.
Alors maintenant, que faire de ces gros manuels
?
Alors moi je les garde, parce qu’ils sont
bien pratiques pour remplir la bibliothèque
quand je tourne des vidéos.
Mais vous, vous pouvez vous en servir comme
support pour poser la casserole, ou bien pour
faire de la musculation, si vous n’aimez
pas les haltères classiques.
[Moi en train de soulever de gros manuels]
« C’est moins fatiguant que de les lire
! ».
Vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour découvrir le meilleur de la pensée.
Allez simplement sur le site 1000 idées de
culture générale.
15ème référence : Soumission à l'autorité
(1974), Stanley Milgram
Le film français I… comme Icare est inspiré
par une théorie controversée sur l’assassinat
du mythique président américain John Fitzgerald
Kennedy. Il raconte l’enquête sur l’assassinat
d’un président. Le procureur apprend que
le tireur présumé avait participé à une
expérience sur l’obéissance à l’autorité.
Pour bien comprendre, il assiste à une expérience
de ce type. Cette scène culte du film est
une reproduction quasi identique de la célèbre
expérience de Stanley Milgram, un psychologue
américain de la prestigieuse université
de Yale (qui devient l'Université de « Layé
» [anagramme de Yale] dans le film).
C’est dans ce livre, pertinemment intitulé
Soumission à l’autorité, que Milgram raconte
les expériences sur la soumission à l’autorité
qu’il a menées en laboratoire dans les
années 1950 et au début des années 1960.
Ce livre est incontournable en psychologie
parce qu’il montre que les atrocités commises
par les nazis ne sont pas une exception historique,
mais que la capacité à faire le mal est
inscrite dans la nature humaine. En effet,
Milgram a commencé ses expériences en 1961,
peu après le début du procès du criminel
nazi Adolf Eichmann, et c’est la défense
d'Eichmann, selon laquelle il n’a fait que
suivre des instructions en ordonnant la mort
de millions de Juifs — c’est cette thèse
qui a suscité l'intérêt de Milgram.
Qu’en dire sur la forme ? C’est un livre
d’un peu plus de 300 pages. Sa structure
suit une démarche méthodique : Milgram passe
de l'introduction du dilemme de l'obéissance
à l'exploration détaillée et l'analyse
des expériences, pour finalement conclure
avec une réflexion critique sur les méthodes
et les implications. Il écrit dans un style
clair, avec des paragraphes et des phrases
plutôt courts. Il y a peu de vocabulaire
technique. Le livre est globalement facile
à lire pour un amateur qui s’intéresse
à la psychologie.
Qu’en retenir sur le fond, maintenant ?
La version la plus célèbre de l’expérience
de Milgram mobilise 40 hommes recrutés à
l’aide d’annonces dans les journaux et
rémunérés 4,5 dollars chacun. Chaque homme
joue le rôle d’un professeur qui doit contrôler
les réponses d’un « étudiant » — en
réalité un acteur complice des chercheurs
— dans une pièce voisine. Lorsque l’étudiant
donne une mauvaise réponse, le professeur
doit lui envoyer un choc électrique (d’intensité
variable), et alors l’acteur fait semblant
de souffrir. Le comportement de l’acteur
évolue au fur et à mesure que l’expérience
progresse : il manifeste de plus en plus sa
souffrance ; il se plaint d’un problème
cardiaque ; il tape sur le mur ; il demande
à être libéré ; à partir d’un certain
point, il est complètement silencieux. La
plupart des participants demandent au chercheur
s’ils doivent continuer à envoyer des chocs,
et ils reçoivent l’ordre de continuer.
Quels sont les résultats de l’expérience
?
La plupart des sujets sont troublés, désemparés,
et même en colère contre le chercheur. Mais…
ils obéissent jusqu’au bout. Le chiffre
à retenir est qu’environ deux tiers des
sujets obéissent jusqu’à envoyer le choc
maximum. La conclusion est que l’homme est
capable de faire souffrir son prochain au-delà
du supportable s’il le fait pour obéir
à une autorité. Milgram écrit : « La disparition
du sens des responsabilités est la conséquence
la plus grave
de la soumission à l'autorité ».
À ses yeux, le niveau élevé d’obéissance
qu’il a obtenu dans ses expériences s’explique
notamment par certains facteurs situationnels
:
* la présence physique d’une figure d’autorité
(l’expérimentateur) ;
* l’encadrement par une institution de confiance
et faisant autorité (la très prestigieuse
université Yale) ;
* le fait que les participants croyaient que
les statuts de professeur et d’étudiant
étaient donnés au hasard ;
* le fait qu’ils supposaient que l'expérimentateur
était un expert compétent ;
* enfin, le fait que les chocs étaient dits
douloureux, et non dangereux.
Malgré son intérêt, l’expérience de
Milgram a suscité la controverse. Elle pose
tout d’abord un problème éthique dans
la mesure où elle risque de troubler les
volontaires en leur révélant qu’ils sont
capables de faire le mal. Ensuite, elle est
difficile à reproduire et, plus particulièrement,
les résultats sont fortement influencés
par un facteur très compliqué à maîtriser,
la perspicacité des sujets (certains critiques
estiment qu’une partie des sujets de Milgram
avaient deviné l’enjeu de l’expérience).
Comment résumer l’influence de ce livre
? Pour faire simple, c’est un peu la réponse
de la psychologie aux horreurs du nazisme.
« L'extermination nazie des Juifs européens
est, écrit Milgram, l'exemple le plus extrême
d'actes immoraux abjects commis par des milliers
de personnes au nom de l'obéissance. Pourtant,
cela se reproduit constamment à un degré
moindre : des citoyens ordinaires reçoivent
l'ordre de détruire d'autres personnes, et
ils le font parce qu'ils considèrent que
c'est leur devoir d'obéir aux ordres. » La
vie collective est impossible sans un système
d’autorité, comme le pose Milgram dans
le premier chapitre, mais les choses peuvent
déraper.
La seconde dimension de l’influence du livre
est éthique. En effet, les expériences de
Milgram demandent de tromper les participants,
et elles engendrent chez certains d’entre
eux une détresse psychologique. Ces caractéristiques
ont suscité des débats sur ce qui est acceptable
dans la recherche sur des sujets humains,
ce qui a conduit à une réévaluation des
normes éthiques dans la recherche en psychologie.
16ème référence : Influence et manipulation
(1984), Robert Cialdini
Comment un patient s’est-il retrouvé à
recevoir des gouttes pour les oreilles dans
l’anus ? Il était venu à l’hôpital
parce qu’il souffrait d’une infection
à l’oreille droite, et le médecin lui
a prescrit des gouttes auriculaires (c’est-à-dire
des gouttes spéciales pour les oreilles).
Mais au lieu d’écrire « right ear » (« oreille
droite ») en toutes lettres sur son ordonnance,
le médecin l’a abrégé en « Place in
GRAND R ear », ce qui, en lisant le grand
R et « ear » à la suite, donne « Place
in rear » (en français… « À déposer
dans le derrière »). L’infirmière a donc
simplement suivi l’instruction. L’absurdité
du traitement d’une otite par voie rectale
saute aux yeux, mais ni l’infirmière ni
le patient ne se sont posés de question.
Le pouvoir d’influence du statut du médecin
était trop fort pour qu’ils exercent leur
esprit critique.
Robert Cialdini raconte cette anecdote dans
Influence et manipulation pour illustrer un
des principes fondamentaux de l’influence.
Il donne beaucoup d’exemples de phénomènes
d’influence dans la vie quotidienne, et
c’est ce qui explique, je pense, l’énorme
popularité du livre. Pour faire simple, ce
livre est la Bible de la persuasion. Il est
notamment très populaire dans le milieu du
marketing et de la vente en ligne. Il y a
7-8 ans, je devais créer une page et un texte
de présentation pour un manuel que je venais
d’écrire, et comme je ne savais pas comment
m’y prendre, un ami m’a recommandé ce
livre (son conseil était plus précisément
de reprendre, un par un, les principes présentés
dans le livre).
Une autre raison de la popularité d’Influence
et manipulation, c’est qu’il est très
accessible. Il est certes un peu long (environ
400 pages), mais Robert Cialdini s’exprime
simplement et clairement. Il raconte beaucoup
d’histoires et d’anecdotes surprenantes
qui sont efficaces pour capter et conserver
l’attention du lecteur. La structure du
livre est également efficace grâce à sa
simplicité : après une introduction générale
et une introduction à la psychologie de l’influence,
Cialdini consacre un chapitre entier à chaque
principe fondamental d’influence (il y en
a sept) ; puis il termine en parlant des enjeux
d’influence (éthiques, en particulier)
de la société moderne et des nouvelles technologies
de l’information.
L’essentiel à connaître du fond de ce
livre, ce sont les 7 principes fondamentaux
d’influence. Je vais donc vous les expliquer
donc un par un.
Le principe de réciprocité est profondément
enraciné dans la nature humaine parce que
nous avons un formidable instinct de coopération.
Il signifie que nous nous sentons automatiquement
redevables lorsqu’on nous offre quelque
chose. Un des exemples emblématiques de Cialdini
est le bonbon offert avec l’addition au
restaurant : c’est pour inciter le client
à laisser un pourboire plus généreux. Un
don crée un petit malaise chez le receveur,
parce qu’il se sent redevable, même s’il
n’aime pas le donneur. C’est pour ça
que le principe de réciprocité joue un rôle
clé dans les affaires internationales, comme
lors de la crise des missiles de Cuba en 1962.
Pour se protéger contre l’influence de
la réciprocité, il faut reconnaître le
don initial comme une tentative de manipulation,
et alors le sentiment de redevabilité disparaît.
Le deuxième principe fondamental d’influence
est la sympathie. La sympathie désigne le
penchant instinctif qui attire des personnes
les unes vers les autres. Elle facilite la
vente dans les réunions Tupperware, par exemple,
parce que l’hôtesse (qui touche un pourcentage
des ventes) est une amie commune à toutes
les participantes présentes. Le principe
de sympathie explique également l’attirance
que nous éprouvons pour les choses familières,
pour les personnes séduisantes ou pour celles
qui nous ressemblent. C’est pour cette raison
que les publicitaires lient les produits à
des célébrités appréciées. Pour se protéger
contre l'influence de la sympathie, il faut
reconnaître une sympathie démesurée et
séparer mentalement l'individu sympathique
de sa requête.
Le troisième principe est la preuve sociale.
Elle signifie que nous déterminons ce qui
est bien en observant ce que les autres pensent
être bien. Par exemple, j’ajoute une poudre
protectrice de la dentition dans les croquettes
de mon chien parce que d’autres propriétaires
m’ont dit qu’ils le font. Les imiter m’a
fait économiser du temps et des efforts.
Mais la preuve sociale peut être manipulée,
comme lorsque le producteur d’un spectacle
paie des personnes pour applaudir et ainsi
influencer les vrais spectateurs à avoir
une opinion favorable du spectacle (c’est
ce qu’on appelle la technique de « la claque
»). Dans le détail, la preuve sociale est
particulièrement puissante lorsque nous ne
savons pas quoi faire, que beaucoup de gens
font le comportement à imiter, et qu’ils
nous ressemblent. Il ne faut pas se fier entièrement
à la preuve sociale sans autres indicateurs.
Le quatrième principe est l’autorité.
Il est rationnel de se soumettre à l’autorité
parce qu’elle est probablement compétente,
et parce qu’on risque d’être sanctionné
si on refuse de se soumettre. L’autorité
est souvent symbolisée par des titres ou
des vêtements spécifiques. Par exemple,
l’année dernière j’ai consulté un chiropracteur
russe parce que je n’arrivais plus à lever
une épaule. Sa froideur m'a d'abord mis mal
à l’aise — mais après avoir parcouru
tous ses diplômes affichés sur les murs
du cabinet, j'ai été rassuré et lui ai
fait totalement confiance (et il a effectivement
résolu mon problème). Le respect de l’autorité
est fort dans l’armée et dans le monde
médical, parce que l’efficacité de la
coopération est cruciale dans ces secteurs.
L’inconvénient, c’est que cela peut engendrer
de grosses erreurs, comme le traitement d’une
otite par voie rectale que j’ai évoqué
au début. Cialdini recommande de vérifier
la compétence et la fiabilité de l’autorité.
Le cinquième principe est la rareté. Il
signifie que les opportunités nous semblent
plus précieuses lorsqu'elles sont limitées.
Par exemple, un cookie pris d'une boîte de
deux semble plus savoureux qu'un cookie pris
d'une boîte de dix. Le Black Friday est le
meilleur exemple du principe de rareté dans
le commerce : les magasins déclenchent le
passage à l’action en offrant d'importantes
réductions pour une durée limitée. Pour
ne pas être manipulé, il faut reconnaître
son agitation et évaluer l'utilité intrinsèque
de la chose rare.
Le sixième principe est la cohérence. C’est
l’absence de contradiction et d'étrangeté
entre les pensées, entre les actes, ou entre
les pensées et les actes. Par exemple, je
souhaite vraiment être en bonne santé, donc
je surveille mon alimentation et je fais du
sport. Une fois qu’il fait un choix ou qu’il
prend position, l’individu est soumis à
deux types de pressions : celles qui le poussent
à être cohérent avec l’image qu’il
a de lui-même ; et celles qui le poussent
à être cohérent avec l’image qu’autrui
a de lui. Si vous vivez dans une grande ville
européenne, vous pouvez voir à l’œuvre
des escrocs qui demandent tout d’abord aux
passants — idéalement des touristes — de
signer une pétition « pour soutenir les
sourds et muets » ; puis ils leur demandent
de faire un don — et si la cible accepte,
un complice observe où son portefeuille est
rangé. Pour se protéger, il faut reconnaître
la pression du principe de cohérence et reconnaître
que cette cohérence particulière n’a pas
de sens.
Le septième et dernier principe est l’unité.
C’est un instinct tribal de coopération
: l’homme est enclin à dire « oui » à
autrui s'il considère qu'il appartient au
même groupe. Par exemple, les conseillers
bancaires prêtent davantage aux personnes
de la même religion. Ce n'est pas simplement
la sympathie, mais l'identité partagée qui
unit les gens par la famille, l'ethnie, ou
même les affiliations politiques et religieuses.
Le principe d’unité est aussi actif dans
la musique, parce qu’elle synchronise les
esprits des membres d'un groupe, ce qui favorise
leur convergence vers des objectifs collectifs.
Le danger du principe d’unité, c’est
qu’il entraîne à défavoriser les individus
qui ne sont pas membres du groupe, voire à
en faire des boucs émissaires. Pour éviter
ce danger, Cialdini recommande de traiter
des individus extérieurs comme des membres,
et de souligner les liens entre les groupes
(comme lorsque l’on parle de l’amitié
franco-allemande, par exemple).
Influence et manipulation est un livre particulièrement
influent — ce qu’on pourrait, après tout,
attendre de lui — il est influent pour les
raisons suivantes :
* La base empirique de la théorie de Cialdini
fait autorité. Il a expérimenté beaucoup
de choses sur ses propres étudiants, mais
il a surtout infiltré des professionnels
de la persuasion (des commerciaux, des quêteurs,
des responsables marketing, des recruteurs,
etc.), et il a en plus consulté les « ennemis
» des professionnels de la persuasion (des
agents de la brigade antifraude, des journalistes
d'investigation, et des agences de protection
du consommateur).
* Ensuite, le livre a popularisé les idées
de la psychologie sociale dans le grand public.
Ce faisant, il a renforcé l’importance
et la crédibilité scientifique de cette
branche. Au tout début du livre, Cialdini
reproche à la psychologie sociale de ne pas
assez démocratiser le savoir qu'elle produit.
* Enfin, le livre a étendu les applications
de la psychologie sociale à divers domaines
tels que le marketing, les affaires, la politique,
et même les interactions quotidiennes. Cialdini
dit qu’il écrit plutôt pour protéger
les potentielles victimes (et c’est vrai
qu’il leur donne des conseils) — mais
ce sont surtout les potentiels bénéficiaires
qui se sont emparés de ce que Cialdini nomme
« la science de la persuasion ».
17ème référence : The Adapted Mind (1992),
Jerome Barkow, Leda Cosmides et John Tooby
Lorsque les psychologues demandent à des
sujets d’observer des images et de reconnaître
des choses sur ces images, la vitesse à laquelle
ils les reconnaissent n’est pas toujours
la même. En particulier, ils perçoivent
bien plus rapidement… les serpents. « Ne
pouvons-nous pas soupçonner, suggère Darwin,
que les peurs des enfants, qui sont tout à
fait indépendantes de l'expérience, sont
les conséquences transmises de dangers réels...
de l'époque sauvage primitive ? » En suivant
cette hypothèse, si nous avons instinctivement
peur des serpents, c’est parce que, il y
a bien longtemps dans l’histoire de l’humanité,
nos ancêtres étaient quotidiennement confrontés
aux serpents.
L’hypothèse de Darwin fonde la nouvelle
école de pensée psychologique dont ce livre,
The Adapted Mind est considéré comme « la
Bible », la psychologie évolutionniste.
Qu’est-ce que la psychologie évolutionniste
? C’est l’étude de la manière dont l’esprit
humain a été façonné par la sélection
naturelle au cours de l’évolution. Plus
précisément, puisque les hommes ont été
des chasseurs-cueilleurs pendant 99 % de leur
histoire, leur esprit serait logiquement,
comme leur corps, le produit d’adaptations
qui ont permis de résoudre les problèmes
posés par l’environnement des chasseurs-cueilleurs.
Ce livre est une référence incontournable
parce que, dans l’histoire de la psychologie,
la psychologie évolutionniste est l’école
de pensée la plus récente et la plus prometteuse.
Elle est certes marginalisée dans le monde
intellectuel francophone, mais son paradigme
s’impose aux États-Unis depuis le début
du XXIe siècle (les universités les plus
prestigieuses proposent des cours et des programmes
de recherche en psychologie évolutionniste).
Concernant la forme, The Adapted Mind est
un livre de pas loin de 700 pages. Et l’éditeur
a voulu économiser du papier en optant pour
de petits caractères, avec un interlignage
serré et un texte qui occupe presque toute
la largeur de la page. Ce n’est pas un essai
cohérent des 3 auteurs présentés sur la
couverture, mais une compilation de 18 articles
écrits par 25 auteurs. Le propos n’est
pas excessivement académique, mais quand
même pas très accessible. Il est parfois
théorique, et il faut réfléchir pour comprendre
les concepts. Après, la structure du propos
est plutôt efficace, et le style est globalement
pragmatique. En conclusion, ce n’est pas
insurmontable pour un amateur, mais il faut
faire des efforts.
Que retenir du fond du livre, maintenant ?
Barkow, Cosmides et Tooby disent que leur
compilation a deux objectifs. Le premier est
de présenter le domaine naissant de la psychologie
évolutionniste à un public scientifique
plus large. Le second objectif du livre est,
en se concentrant sur la manière dont l'esprit
humain traite l'information, de montrer comment
la psychologie évolutionniste relie la biologie
évolutive aux phénomènes complexes étudiés
par les anthropologues, les sociologues, les
économistes et les historiens. C’est pour
ça que le livre est sous-titré « La psychologie
évolutionniste et la formation de la culture
».
L’introduction et la première partie du
livre sont les parties les plus importantes
— elles représentent d’ailleurs 20 % du
contenu — elles sont les parties les plus
importantes parce qu’elles parlent de la
psychologie évolutionniste en général et
de son rôle fondateur pour les sciences sociales
(c’est-à-dire toutes les disciplines qui
étudient les aspects sociaux et culturels
de l'existence humaine). Tooby et Cosmides
(deux des trois noms qui sont sur la couverture)
remettent en question le paradigme actuel
des sciences sociales selon lequel presque
tout, dans l’esprit humain, vient de l’éducation.
À leurs yeux, se contenter de distinguer
l’inné, qui serait la nature, et l’acquis,
qui serait l’éducation — cette distinction
ne serait pas la bonne voie pour comprendre
l’esprit humain. La distinction la plus
efficace porte sur la manière dont les mécanismes
psychologiques interagissent avec l'environnement
: certains mécanismes psychologiques sont
« ouverts » dans le sens où ils peuvent
varier en fonction des influences extérieures
; d'autres sont en revanche « fermés », c’est-à-dire
qu’ils restent essentiellement les mêmes
quel que soit l’environnement.
L’autre idée importante pour comprendre
le paradigme de la psychologie évolutionniste
est la spécialisation des mécanismes psychologiques.
Pour Tooby et Cosmides, il n’y a pas de
mécanismes psychologiques « généraux ». L’esprit
humain n’est pas un ordinateur polyvalent
qui fonctionnerait de la même manière que
l'on joue aux échecs ou que l'on commande
une pizza. Il ressemble plutôt à un réseau
complexe d'ordinateurs, chacun spécialisé
dans une fonction. Par exemple, nous possédons
un mécanisme psychologique spécialisé pour
reconnaître les visages humains, et il fonctionne
différemment de notre capacité à reconnaître
d'autres objets. Il nous permet notamment
de reconnaître des visages familiers même
dans une foule. Selon les deux auteurs, ces
mécanismes spécifiques sont plus rapides
et plus efficaces, et c'est la combinaison
de ces mécanismes spécifiques qui rend le
comportement humain si flexible et intelligent.
Après les 140 premières pages qui traitent
de la psychologie évolutionniste et de son
rôle pour les sciences sociales, les parties
suivantes traitent de questions spécifiques
du point de vue évolutionniste : la coopération
; la psychologie de l’accouplement et de
la sexualité, sujet qui a fait du premier
auteur de cette partie, David Buss, un écrivain
à succès et une petite célébrité sur
internet (il a également écrit le manuel
de référence de la psychologie évolutionniste)
; la quatrième partie concerne la prise en
charge des enfants par les parents ; ensuite,
la perception et le langage comme des adaptations
; l’esthétique de l’environnement ; les
processus intrapsychiques ; et enfin, les
phénomènes culturels.
Pour faire simple, je vais vous résumer grossièrement
le point de vue de la psychologie évolutionniste
sur les thèmes les plus emblématiques du
livre :
* La coopération est un trait développé
au fil de l'évolution, car elle favorise
la survie et la reproduction du groupe humain.
* La psychologie de l’accouplement et de
la sexualité favorise les comportements qui
donnent les meilleures chances d’avoir une
progéniture. La conclusion de la psychologie
évolutionniste, qui est répétée à foison
sur YouTube et les réseaux sociaux, est que
les hommes sont attirés par la jeunesse et
la beauté, qui sont des signes de fertilité,
tandis que les femmes privilégient les ressources
et le statut, qui indiquent la capacité de
l’homme à soutenir le développement la
progéniture.
* Les parents élèvent leurs enfants de manière
à maximiser la transmission de leurs gènes
(ce qui explique par exemple qu’ils consacrent
plus de ressources à un enfant qui a de meilleures
chances de survie).
* La perception est un mécanisme mental spécialisé
développé au cours de l'évolution pour
nous aider à interagir avec notre environnement
de manière efficace. Par exemple, nous reconnaissons
rapidement les serpents parce qu’ils représentaient
une menace mortelle constante pour nos ancêtres
chasseurs-cueilleurs.
* Le langage est un mécanisme de l’esprit
humain qui décuple l’efficacité de la
coopération. Par exemple, il permettait de
planifier et de coordonner des chasses complexes,
où chaque membre de la tribu avait un rôle
spécifique.
* Enfin, les hommes éprouvent du plaisir
à contempler les environnements qui sont
favorables à leur survie. Par exemple, ils
aiment lorsqu’il y a des arbres, parce que
les arbres les protègent du soleil et des
dangers.
Comment expliquer l’influence de ce livre
en psychologie ? Il est le livre qui marque
le changement de paradigme dominant (tout
du moins dans le monde anglo-saxon, qui est
l’aire culturelle des plus grands psychologues
contemporains). Ensuite, ce livre symbolise
le nouveau rôle revendiqué par la psychologie
dans le savoir humain : elle n’est plus
une discipline intellectuelle mineure ; en
devenant évolutionniste, elle prétend carrément
changer le paradigme des sciences sociales.
En donnant une nouvelle vision de l’homme,
elle donne une nouvelle vision du savoir.
Une des conclusions majeures de la psychologie
évolutionniste est qu’il existe bien une
nature humaine. Qu’est-ce que la nature
humaine ? C’est l’ensemble des mécanismes
universels de l’esprit humain. Par exemple,
la peur des serpents est un élément de la
nature humaine.
18ème référence : L’intelligence émotionnelle,
(1995) Daniel Goleman
Daniel Goleman rapporte le cas de Gary, un
brillant chirurgien américain. En plus d’être
intelligent, il est cultivé : il a des connaissances
très étendues en art et en science. Et pourtant…
les gens le trouvent terne. Il est incapable
de ressentir, d’exprimer ou même de reconnaître
les émotions. Lorsque sa fiancée Ellen lui
dit qu’elle se sent déprimée, il est indifférent
; si elle lui parle d’amour, il change de
sujet. Cherchant désespérément une étincelle
de vie en lui, elle l’a envoyé voir un
thérapeute. Gary est un exemple de ce que
les psychiatres nomment l’« alexithymie
» (ce mot est formé à partir du a- privatif,
du grec lexis qui signifie « parole », et
du grec thymos, qu’on peut traduire par
« émotion »). L'alexithymie est l'incapacité
à reconnaître ou à exprimer ses propres
émotions.
Comme son titre le suggère, ce livre, L’intelligence
émotionnelle, réhabilite les émotions,
qu’on peut définir comme des chocs psychiques
momentanés, agréables (telles la joie ou
la surprise) ou pénibles (telles la colère
ou la peur). On assimile souvent les émotions
à ce que les philosophes appelaient les passions,
mais il y a une différence importante : les
passions sont plus durables et peuvent grandement
influencer la pensée et le comportement d'une
personne. On considère souvent les émotions
comme étant à l'opposé du QI, et donc en
contradiction avec l'intelligence et le succès.
Mais Daniel Goleman montre que c’est faux.
Son livre est une référence incontournable
en psychologie parce qu’il redéfinit l’intelligence.
Sur la forme, L’intelligence émotionnelle
fait 350 pages. Sa structure est progressive
et cohérente : Goleman guide le lecteur depuis
les fondements biologiques des émotions jusqu'à
leur application concrète dans la vie quotidienne,
tout en soulignant l'importance d'une compréhension
approfondie des émotions et d’une éducation
aux émotions. Goleman a beau être docteur
en psychologie, il est devenu journaliste
au New York Times, et donc il écrit avec
le style simple, clair et dynamique d’un
journaliste. Les paragraphes et les phrases
sont plutôt courts ; le vocabulaire pèche
rarement par sa technicité. Les exemples
et les anecdotes sont nombreux, et Goleman
commence la plupart des chapitres par du storytelling.
Bref, on peut emporter ce livre à la plage.
Qu’en retenir sur le fond, maintenant ?
La première idée essentielle du livre est
la dualité de la raison et de l’émotion.
En effet, l'être humain est complexe. D'un
côté, il a une incroyable capacité de réflexion
; mais de l’autre côté, ses émotions
sont parfois irrationnelles. Elles peuvent
le submerger, même face à la logique. Par
exemple, même avec tous les outils technologiques
à notre disposition, un sentiment passager
peut avoir le dernier mot sur nos choix. Mais
ce phénomène n’est pas nouveau. Des recherches
en neurosciences ont montré que notre héritage
génétique comporte des circuits émotionnels
vieux de 50 000 générations. Cela signifie
que nos ancêtres ressentaient, eux aussi,
ces émotions fortes. Cette capacité à ressentir
des émotions fortes était même une clé
de leur survie.
La deuxième idée essentielle du livre est
celle qui lui donne son titre : l'intelligence
émotionnelle. L'intelligence ne se limite
pas à la capacité à réfléchir ou à résoudre
des problèmes. L’intelligence des émotions
est une autre forme d’intelligence qui nous
permet de comprendre, de gérer et d’exprimer
nos émotions. Elle est tout aussi cruciale
que le QI. Prenons un exemple concret : deux
individus ont un QI élevé, mais l'un d'eux
est plus empathique. Cette empathie, partie
de l'intelligence émotionnelle, lui permet
de mieux interagir avec les autres. Goleman
estime qu'ignorer cette forme d'intelligence
est un risque, car elle est essentielle pour
nos relations et pour notre bien-être.
La troisième idée essentielle du livre concerne
l’éducation émotionnelle. Nos émotions
ne sont pas gravées dans la pierre. Nous
pouvons les comprendre et les gérer. Bien
que façonnée par les expériences de l'enfance,
l'intelligence émotionnelle peut être cultivée
et renforcée tout au long de notre vie adulte.
Comment faire ? Par l'éducation émotionnelle.
Cette éducation consiste à apprendre à
reconnaître ses émotions et à y répondre.
C'est comme apprendre à lire ou à écrire.
Prenons le cas d’une personne qui ressent
une colère soudaine. Si cette personne est
éduquée émotionnellement, alors elle peut
identifier sa colère, comprendre sa cause,
et choisir la meilleure réaction. Sans éducation
émotionnelle, elle pourrait simplement exploser.
Goleman insiste sur l’importance de cet
apprentissage parce qu’il nous aide à vivre
en harmonie avec nous-mêmes et avec les autres.
D’ailleurs, les études montrent que les
personnes formées à la gestion des émotions
ont une meilleure santé mentale et des relations
plus saines.
La principale dimension de l’influence de
ce livre en psychologie est la remise en cause
du QI comme unique indicateur de l'intelligence
et de la réussite. C’était la norme de
mesurer l’intelligence par le QI, puis Goleman
a popularisé l’idée de l’intelligence
émotionnelle. À ses yeux, la logique et
les maths sont en réalité moins importantes
que de savoir gérer ses émotions et de comprendre
celles des autres. Cette conclusion confirme
un sentiment personnel : j’ai toujours trouvé
que certaines personnes brillantes par leur
rationalité, et qui obtiennent de gros scores
aux tests de QI, sont capables d’une grande
stupidité parce qu’elles négligent ou
méconnaissent des aspects élémentaires
de la nature humaine. Est-on vraiment intelligent
lorsqu’on raisonne en ignorant la nature
humaine ?
Pour finir, l’influence de ce livre a dépassé
la psychologie. Il a notamment incité le
monde de l’entreprise à valoriser l’intelligence
émotionnelle. Les managers, en particulier,
doivent savoir gérer émotionnellement leur
équipe.
19ème référence : The Lucifer Effect (2007),
Philip Zimbardo
En 1971, Philip Zimbardo, qui est prof à
l’Université de Stanford, la plus prestigieuse
de Californie, mène l’expérience qui sera
la plus controversée de l’histoire de la
psychologie. Elle consiste à faire jouer
à des étudiants ordinaires le rôle de prisonniers
et de gardiens de prison (et l’attribution
des rôles est aléatoire). Alors que l'étude
est censée durer deux semaines, elle doit
être interrompue au bout de six jours seulement,
car les gardiens sont trop violents et les
prisonniers montrent des signes de stress
et d'anxiété extrêmes.
C’est dans ce livre, The Lucifer Effect
(« L’effet Lucifer » en français), que
Philip Zimbardo raconte pour la première
fois l’histoire de l’expérience, dite
« expérience de Stanford », qui l’a rendu
célèbre. Ce livre est une référence incontournable
en psychologie à la fois parce qu’il est
associé à la célèbre expérience, et parce
qu’il révolutionne la psychologie sociale
avec l’idée dérangeante suggérée par
le titre : chaque homme est capable de faire
le mal.
Sur la forme, The Lucifer Effect compte pas
loin de 600 pages. C’est certainement trop
pour expliquer le message essentiel. La description
de l’expérience de Stanford dure, à elle
seule, 5-6 chapitres sur un total de 16, soit
environ un tiers du livre. Zimbardo répète
les mêmes idées à travers différentes
histoires et expériences. Peut-être que
je me trompe, mais j’imagine qu’un éditeur,
alléché par la popularité de Zimbardo,
l’a poussé à écrire un gros livre alors
que la matière ne suffisait pas. Après,
le propos est accessible. Le style de Zimbardo
est clair et direct. C’est globalement efficace,
mais le récit détaillé des expériences
n’est pas passionnant pour l’amateur (d’autant
plus qu’elles illustrent la même thèse).
Maintenant, que retenir sur le fond ?
Le livre détaille l'expérience de Stanford,
dirigée par Zimbardo lui-même. Il examine
ensuite des tragédies mondiales, comme le
génocide rwandais de 1994, et le scandale
d'Abou Ghraib (lors de la guerre en Irak),
en mettant l'accent sur les défaillances
systémiques plutôt que sur les fautes individuelles
des gardiens. En fin d'ouvrage, Zimbardo propose
des pistes pour résister aux forces qui nous
poussent à commettre des actes malveillants.
La première idée essentielle est que n’importe
qui peut faire le mal. Dans les faits, tout
le monde a déjà fait quelque chose qu'il
n'aurait pas dû, surtout si la situation
le permettait. Pourtant, nous aimons croire
que certaines personnes sont naturellement
bonnes et d'autres mauvaises. En réalité,
la frontière entre le bien et le mal est
floue. Prenons Ivan "Chip" Frederick, un ancien
sergent de l'armée américaine. Avant de
travailler à la prison d'Abou Ghraib, connue
pour la torture de prisonniers irakiens en
2003, Frederick était un homme ordinaire.
C’est la prison d’Abou Ghraib qui a fait
ressortir le pire en lui.
La conclusion — et deuxième idée essentielle
du livre — est que la situation influence
fortement le comportement de l’individu.
Un homme n’est pas le simple produit de
sa nature. C’est le contexte dans lequel
l’homme est placé, et non pas sa personnalité
individuelle, qui détermine son comportement
(et en particulier sa propension à faire
souffrir son prochain). La pression sociale
ou l'autorité le poussent parfois à agir
contre ses principes. Ainsi, une situation
spéciale peut rapidement transformer un individu
bienveillant en quelqu'un capable de commettre
des actes malveillants : Zimbardo baptise
ce phénomène l’« effet Lucifer » (Lucifer
est un ange déchu assimilé au diable dans
les traditions chrétiennes). « Si vous mettez
de bonnes pommes dans une mauvaise situation,
écrit Zimbardo, vous obtiendrez de mauvaises
pommes. » L'expérience de Stanford est un
exemple flagrant du phénomène. Des étudiants
ordinaires sont devenus des gardiens cruels
ou des prisonniers soumis dans une fausse
prison. Le contexte et les rôles qu'ils ont
joués les ont transformés. La situation
peut donc surpasser la personnalité.
La troisième idée essentielle du livre concerne
la déshumanisation, c’est-à-dire le fait
de considérer et de traiter quelqu’un comme
s’il était inférieur à un être humain.
Zimbardo explique que la déshumanisation
facilite les mauvais traitements. C'est un
mécanisme de justification : si nous ne voyons
pas les autres comme des égaux, il est plus
facile de leur faire du mal. C'est l’interprétation
que donne Zimbardo de ce qui s’est passé
à Abou Ghraib. Les gardiens ont vu les prisonniers
non pas comme des personnes, mais comme des
ennemis. Cette déshumanisation les a conduits
à commettre des atrocités.
Le livre se termine par un chapitre de recommandations
(assez vagues) pour éviter qu’une situation
ne fasse ressortir le pire en nous. Zimbardo
encourage le lecteur à assumer ses actes
et à rejeter les excuses faciles. En amont,
il faut se méfier des autorités injustes
et des discours trompeurs. Enfin, Zimbardo
promeut l’idéal du héros : agir lorsque
la majorité reste passive, et toujours privilégier
le bien-être d'autrui.
Comme ce livre date de 2007, il est un peu
tôt pour examiner son influence sur la pensée
psychologique. Mais ce qu’on peut dire,
c’est qu’il rééquilibre le rapport entre
la personnalité et le contexte dans la psychologie
sociale. Ce qu’on peut même dire plus précisément
sur le plan des idées, c’est que Zimbardo
affine la thèse de Milgram : ce n'est pas
seulement la soumission à l'autorité qui
peut transformer un individu ordinaire en
bourreau, mais plutôt la situation elle-même.
Enfin, il y a aussi une autre potentielle
dimension de l’influence de ce livre : comme
l’expérience de Milgram, l’expérience
de Stanford (qui a été très médiatisée)
a ravivé le débat sur les limites éthiques
de la recherche en psychologie.
20ème référence : Système 1 / Système
2 : Les deux vitesses de la pensée (2011),
Daniel Kahneman
J’ai déjà choisi ce livre dans ma vidéo
sur les 20 références d’économie incontournables,
qui date d’octobre 2021. Et dans cette vidéo,
je précise que le livre a près de 22 000
notes sur le site américain d’Amazon. À
l’heure où j’écris ce script, à l’été
2023, il y a désormais… plus de 40 500
notes (et tout de même plus de 650 pour la
traduction française sur le site français
d’Amazon) ! Ces chiffres impressionnants
sont cohérents avec le fait que Daniel Kahneman
est considéré comme un des penseurs les
plus influents au monde (en plus d’être
un des grands noms de la psychologie moderne).
Et Système 1 / Système 2 : Les deux vitesses
de la pensée représente ses mémoires intellectuelles.
Dans ce livre, qui est son premier destiné
au grand public, il résume l'œuvre de sa
vie à partir de décennies de recherche.
Et ce résumé est devenu incontournable en
psychologie parce que c’est la référence
sur une théorie devenue très populaire au
début du XXIe siècle — une théorie qui
semble donner les clés du fonctionnement
de l’esprit humain, qu’elle réduit à
des automatismes simples : j’ai nommé la
théorie des biais cognitifs.
Le concept de « biais cognitif » a été
créé dans les années 1970 par Kahneman
lui-même et par son compère, qui est également
un psychologue israélien, Amos Tversky, lorsqu’ils
étudiaient l’irrationalité des décisions
économiques. Dans la langue ordinaire, un
biais est un angle sous lequel une chose se
présente. L’idée derrière l’expression
de « biais cognitif » est donc que l’esprit
humain comprend une chose sous un certain
angle qui n’est pas une représentation
fidèle de la réalité, et qui, pour cette
raison, conduit à l’erreur. Par exemple,
nous avons tendance à généraliser les expériences
de notre vie quotidienne.
Les biais cognitifs sont des raccourcis de
notre cerveau qui bousculent la logique. Ils
sont nés de l'évolution pour simplifier
et accélérer notre façon de penser. En
effet, raisonner de manière approfondie demande
du temps et des efforts. Les biais cognitifs
ressemblent à ce que nous appelons souvent
« préjugés ». Ils nous aident à décider
rapidement, tout en préservant nos ressources
mentales comme la mémoire et l'attention.
Par exemple, depuis que je me suis tordu la
cheville en marchant dans l'herbe sur le côté
du chemin où je promène mon chien, j’évite
instinctivement de marcher à cet endroit,
sans avoir à évaluer systématiquement la
dangerosité du terrain à chaque fois. Je
prends une mesure de sécurité simple et
efficace tout en économisant des ressources
mentales.
Après cette petite digression sur les biais
cognitifs, je reviens à Système 1 / Système
2 : Les deux vitesses de la pensée.
Quoi dire concernant la forme de ce livre
?
C’est un pavé de 700 pages, donc il ne
faut pas être pressé. Le lecteur sera quand
même motivé par la puissance de fascination
du sujet, qui laisse imaginer qu’on va découvrir
les « secrets » de la pensée. Après, Kahneman
— qui est un véritable scientifique et
pas un vulgarisateur — Kahneman mentionne
quand même beaucoup d’études, et il en
parle avec du vocabulaire technique. Mais
il écrit avec un style simple et moderne,
sur le mode de la conversation (il s’adresse
au lecteur en le vouvoyant).
Que retenir du fond du livre, maintenant ?
L’idée fondamentale est, comme l’indique
le titre, qu’il existe 2 vitesses de fonctionnement
du cerveau — que Kahneman nomme « système
1 » et « système 2 ».
Le « système 1 », tout d’abord, fonctionne
de manière automatique et inconsciente. C’est
notre cerveau intuitif, qui réagit automatiquement,
inconsciemment, et très rapidement à notre
environnement. Il le fait en nous fournissant
des informations imparfaites, voire illusoires
— ce qui rend possible la manipulation psychologique.
Nous utilisons par exemple ce « système
1 » pour lire des phrases faciles, résoudre
des problèmes mathématiques simples, ou
percevoir des objets qui entrent dans une
catégorie.
À l’évidence, nous n’avons pas intérêt
à nous fier à ce premier système. Il fonctionne
en effet par des biais, de telle sorte qu’il
nous entraîne à prendre de mauvaises décisions.
Par exemple, lorsque nous lisons une phrase
particulièrement compliquée, qui demande
un effort de réflexion supplémentaire, le
« système 1 » nous pousse à substituer
au véritable sens de cette phrase compliquée
un sens plus facile.
Le « système 1 » prédomine naturellement,
c’est pourquoi notre jugement est conditionné
par des biais cognitifs. La 2ème partie du
livre répertorie les grands biais cognitifs.
Kahneman évoque par exemple l’« ancrage
», le fait que les informations reçues en
premier se fixent solidement, telle l’ancre
d’un bateau, dans l’esprit humain, au
point que nous négligeons les informations
que nous découvrons ultérieurement. Pour
le dire plus simplement, nous accordons trop
d’importance à la première impression.
Maintenant, qu’est-ce que le « système
2 » ? C’est notre cerveau rationnel. Il
s’agit d’une mécanique puissante, mais
lente au démarrage (contrairement au « système
1 », qui opère à la vitesse de l’éclair).
Nous utilisons le « système 2 » pour mener
des raisonnements et résoudre des problèmes
difficiles. Ce mode de pensée nous permet
également de nous concentrer sur un sujet.
Étant donné que le « système 2 » coûte
plus d’efforts et qu’il est dans la nature
humaine d’éviter les efforts, nous dépendons
du « système 1 ».
Kahneman analyse ensuite d’autres questions
à travers le prisme de l’opposition entre
le « système 1 » et le « système 2 » : l’excès
de confiance en soi, notre difficulté à
interpréter les statistiques, et la mesure
du bien-être.
Comment expliquer l’influence de ce livre
sur la pensée psychologique ?
C’est trop tôt pour conclure, mais on peut
quand même dire 3 choses :
1. Ce livre révolutionne la manière dont
les psychologues comprennent la prise de décision.
Avant, ils la concevaient comme un processus
rationnel. Mais Kahneman explique que deux
systèmes de pensée distincts coexistent
dans l’esprit humain, et que la rationalité
au sens traditionnel ne correspond qu’à
un seul des deux systèmes.
2. Ce livre popularise la théorie des biais
cognitifs. Il y a notamment l'aversion à
la perte, l'ancrage, l'effet de cadrage, ou
encore la surconfiance. Les connaître et
les reconnaître permet d'identifier des schémas
d'erreurs prévisibles dans la pensée.
3. Enfin, ce livre a aussi influencé la pensée
économique (raison pour laquelle je l’ai
inclus dans ma liste des 20 références économiques
incontournables). Pour faire simple, Kahneman
réfute scientifiquement, et expérimentalement,
le postulat de la théorie économique classique
selon lequel l’acteur économique est un
pur calculateur qui prend des décisions rationnelles
(autrement dit, la théorie économique classique
réduit la décision économique à ce que
Kahneman appelle le « système 2 »). En
réalité, la plupart des décisions économiques
sont le fruit des automatismes de l’esprit
humain (ce que Kahneman appelle le « système
1 »).
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.